nous allons
commencer je sais qu'un certain
nombre d'entre vous veulent aller aussi
dans
l'hémicycle donc on va commencer sans
plus tarder et nous poursuivons notre
cycle de d'audition budgétaire en
recevant cet après-midi madame Sylv
retaillot ministre de l'Enseignement
supérieur et et de la recherche pour
nous présenter les crédits de son
ministère pour l'année 2024 madame la
ministre notre comm vous le savez
particulièrement attentive aux
problématiques relatives à
l'enseignement supérieur et et à la
recherche et je ne peux m'empêcher ici
d'évoquer nos travaux sur le projet de
loi de programmation de la recherche que
nous avons profondément amendé à
l'occasion de son examen en octobre 2020
nous restons particulièrement vigilant
concernant la mise en œuvre de ce texte
dont 2024 constua une nouvelle marche
destinée à mieux financer la recherche
française améliorer l'attractivité des
métiers qui la font vivre et replacer la
science dans une relation ouverte avec
la société
notre rapporteur nous avait part en
particulier alerté l'année dernière sous
la sousexécution des créations de postes
inscrites dans le dans le budget vous
nous préciserez sans doute dans les
minutes à venir si les difficultés
réglementaires freinant la mise en œuvre
de laalpr en ce domaine ont été levés au
cours de de l'année qui s'achève de même
nous attendons en savoir plus concernant
l'éventuelle mise en œuvre de la clause
de revoyure prévue par le texte qui
devait avoir lieu d'ici la fin de
l'année 2023 on peut imaginer qu'elle va
être décalée du coup si nous sommes
attentifs à la mise en œuvre de la LPR
nous restons également vigilant sur
l'évolution des conditions de vie des
étudiants la mission d'information
présidée par Pierre ououyas et dont
j'étais rapporteur soulignait la
nécessité d'un meilleur accompagnement
des étudiants que ce soit dans leur dans
leurs études leur santé
ou leur logement nous y évoquions
notamment la nécessité d'une refonte
globale du système de bourse sur
critères sociaux votre ministère s'est
saisi de cette question et et des
consultations sont sont en cours vous
nous en parlerai très probablement
pouvez-vous faire un point sur
l'avancement de ce dossier quels sont
les pistes que vous étudiez
prioritairement en ce domaine et quels
sont quel est le calendrier que vous
comptez suivre par ailleurs à initiative
de notre collègue Pierre-Antoine Lévi le
Parlement a adopté en avril dernier une
loi visant à permettre à tous les
étudiants de bénéficier d'une offre de
restauration à à tarif modéré à
proximité de leur lieu d'étude ou d'une
aide financière dans le cas contraire
pouvez-vous nous indiquer comment cette
loi sera mise en œuvre dès cette année
enfin Madame la ministre nous avons
entendu vos propos concernant la la non
compensation intégrale des dernières
mesures de revalorisation salariale
annoncé par le gouvernement vous avez
indiqué qu'il n'y aurait pas de miracle
je vous cite en en invitant les
opérateurs et les universités à recourir
si nécessaire à la part mobilisable de
leur fond de roulement ces déclarations
ont été accueillies avec une certaine
inquiétude par les universités de
manière générale par l'ensemble des
opérateurs de votre ministère mes
collègues rapporteurs ne manqueront pas
de vous interroger sur ce sujet au
moment de de leur intervention je vais à
présent vous laisser la parole pour un
propos liminaire euh madame la ministre
pour nous présenter les principales
orientations de votre budget après quoi
je céderai euh la parole à à notre
rapporteur pour les crédits et
enseignement supérieur Stéphane piernoir
et à notre nouveau nouvel rapporteur
pour les crédits recherches Laurence
Garnier puis à l'ensemble des
commissaires bien entendu qui
souhaiteront prendre la parole je
rappelle pour terminer que cette
audition est captée et diffusée en
direct sur le site du Sénat madame la
ministre vous avez la
parole merci monsieur le Président
Madame et monsieur le rapporteur
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
sénatrices alors tout d'abord peut-être
vous dire j'ai noté vos questions je les
développerai dans un second temps je
vais d'abord poser effectivement le
paysage et vous dire que c'est à nouveau
un vrai plaisir d'être avec vous pour
pouvoir échanger devant cette commission
votre commission pour discuter de ce
nouveau budget 2024 budget du ministère
de l'Enseignement supérieur et de la
recherche à nouveau ce budget 2024 est
en augmentation avec cette année 1,2
milliards de moyens nouveaux par rapport
au tendenciel prévu c'est 20 % de plus
dans le budget depuis 2017 c'est 8 % de
plus depuis 2022 à titre de comparaison
alors je voudrais définir plusieurs
points comme vous l'avez fait
premièrement ce budget 2024 vise à aider
plus et à aider mieux les étudiants et
donc je vais parler effectivement de la
vie étudiante les engagements que
j'avais pris devant le Parlement devant
vous donc sont tenus puisque le PLF
traduit ses mesures que j'avais annoncé
en particulier sur la réforme des
bourses étape 1 en avril dernier elles
apportent plus de 500 millions d'euros
en effectivement par rapport au
tendantiel prévu d'amélioration au
système de bourse sur critères sociaux
j'eviendrait à l'accès à la restauration
et au logement ainsi que pour mieux
aider plus et mieux les étudiants alors
effectivement d'une part il y a eu cette
annonce de la première étape de la
réforme des bourses c'est environ 400
millions d'euros sur ces 500 de dépenses
en plus par rapport à
2024 en plus en 2024 pardon et d'autre
part la pérenisation du repas à 1 € pour
tous les étudiants boursiers de façon
automatique mais aussi les étudiants
précaires ainsi que le gel des tarifs de
restauration et des loyers ceci pour
tous les étudiants ces mesures sont
compensées et soclé au niveau du knous à
hauteur de 70 millions d'euros pour les
mesures de restauration et de logement
alors nos étudiants perçoivent
effectivement en cette rentrée des
bourses sur critères sociaux qui ont été
revalorisé avec on peut le dire un
investissement historique qui était plus
que nécessaire dans le contexte en
particulier d'inflation
que nous connaissons cette première
étape de la réforme va au-delà de la
d'une simple
revalorisation simple revalorisation des
montants pour chaque échelon puisque
nous nous nous nous attaquons également
à ce qu'on appelle dans le modèle des
bourses les effets de seuil nous
renforçons aussi nos aides aux étudiants
en situation de handicap et aux
étudiants en situation
d'd ce PLF pour 2024 c'est donc aussi
une hausse des dotations investissement
du knous de 25 millions d'euros soit
plus de 25 % pour construire et rénover
des restaurants et des résidences
universitaires ces crédits permettront
en particulier de poursuivre la
réhabilitation des places d'hébergement
avec un objectif de 12000 rénovations
d'ici 2027 conformément aux annonces de
la première ministre lors des du cadre
de CNR
jeunesse c'est aussi 25 million d'euros
pour développer la restauration
conformément à la loi du 13 avril 2023
visant à favoriser l'accès à tous les
étudiants à une offre de restauration à
tarif modéré dite lois Levi que je salue
ici via de nouveaux conventionnements
avec des organismes partenaires mais
aussi avec la mise en place progressive
d'une aide financière pour dire faire un
peu ce qu'on appelle le dernier
kilomètre pour pour les étudiants qui
n'auraient malgré les conventions
passées aucune solution collective de
proximité pour pouvoir avoir accès à
cette restauration à tarif modéré le
knous recevra également une dotation en
plus des 25 millions de 5 millions
d'euros pour accompagner le coût de
fonctionnement lié à l'ouverture de
nouvelles places de restauration et un
recrutement supplémentaire de 38 agents
du cru pour les
restaurations toujours concernant le
knous et les CROUS un amendement du
Gouvernement est sur le point d'être
déposé cet amendement ce nouvel
amendement du Gouvernement permettra de
relever le plafond d'emploi pour lescous
les CROUS de 110
ETPT je pense que c'est une nouvelle
importante qui mesure aussi ben
l'augmentation des flux étudiants par
rapport au cru et à toutes les mesures
que l'on a prises ce relèvement du
plafond d'emploi est historique puisque
je le rappelle ce plafond n'avait pas
évolué depuis 2014 pour
lescnous il permettra d'accompagner la
croissance de l'activité du réseau avec
ces 110 ETPT supplémentaires pour
accompagner
l'icnous c'était aussi une
recommandation de votre rapport sur la
vie étudiante monsieur le Président et
vraiment aujourd'hui je suis heureuse de
pouvoir venir dire devant votre
commission devant vous tous que vous
aviez raison c'est nécessaire et nous le
faisons cette année ainsi une enveloppe
de 100 millions d'euros est dédiée au
renforcement de l'accompagnement aussi
des étudiants en situation de handicap
conformément aux annonce de la
Conférence nationale du handicap et à
une loi qui est aussi passée au niveau
du
Sénat le deuxème point c'est sur ce
budget 2024 permet aussi de soutenir la
recherche vous en avez parlé et les
chercheurs en confirmant cette année
encore la trajectoire en crédit et en
emploi de la loi de la Programm de
programmation de la recherche d'ilpr
soit 468 millions d'euros
supplémentaires sur le périmètre du MESR
et une marge de 500 millions d'euros si
on inclut les crédits dédiés à la
recherche spatiale sur le programme
193 ces crédits financeront plusieurs
points en particulier des points liés
aux ressources humaines comme des
revalorisations sanariales pour 138
millions d'euros de plus des
recrutements additionnels de chercheurs
avec un schéma schéma d'emplat rehaussé
de 650 ETP notamment pour des contrats
doctoraux supplémentaires mais aussi des
chaires de professeurs juniors
supplémentaires au niveau de la masse
salariale il s'agit de plus 91 millions
d'euros associés à ces 650 ETP
supplémentaires au-delà de ce schéma
d'emploi de laalpr je voudrais signaler
73 recrutements supplémentaires qui
seront autorisés pour la recherche sur
le nucléaire civil au
CEA il y a aussi des projets de
recherche en particulier ce sélectionnés
par laanr avec une augmentation du
budget de plus 123 millions d'euros des
investissements dans les équipements
dans le les organisations scientifiques
internationales et les organismes de
recherche pour 52 millions EUR et divers
autres mesures pour un montant de 65
millions d'euros sur la
laalpr afin de s'assurer de la bonne
poursuite de nos objectifs je souhaite
que nous puissions en mesurer les effets
par comparaison en particulier à
l'international à l'Europe en
particulier mais aussi à l'international
en travaillant par exemple avec des
organisations comme l'OCDE afin de
nourrir ce bilan après 3 années vous
l'avez dit de déploiement de la LPR que
je souhaite venir fa faire devant vous
en début d'année
2024 ce budget 2024 vise également et
c'est mon 3ème point à accompagner les
transformations des universités en effet
une enveloppe de 15 millions d'euros est
dédié au financement de la 3e année de
Bachelor Universitaire de Technologie
Dib et à l'ouverture de nouveau
département d'institut universitaire des
technologies renforçant l'accès à
l'Enseign supérieur dans tous les
territoires si vous avez écouté mon
discours dit de Carcassonne auprès des
villes universitaires c'est un pan que
nous souhaitons fortement porter
globalement et développer cette année
sur l'accès territorial à nos étudiants
sur le
territoire
national les financements alloués aux
études de santé sont aussi en hausse de
7 millions d'euros nous poursuivons
également le déploiement des contrats
d'objectifs de moyens et de performance
avec les état établissement avec une
deuxième vague de 42 nouveaux
établissements signataires après une
première vague de 36 établissements en
train de de s'achever chaque année ce
seront donc 100 millions d'euros de
moyens àouer à tous les établissements
dans le cadre de ce comp de ces contrats
d'objectifs de moyens et de performance
qui est une sorte de dialogue
stratégique rénové permettant pour les
établissements une visibilité budgétaire
pluriannuelle enfin et c'est mon 4è et
dernier point ce budget vise à soutenir
le pouvoir d'achat dans un contexte
budgétaire contraint vous le savez le
contexte des finances publiques est
tendu l'inflation reste importante même
si elle se ralentit et la dette de la
France s'alourdit dans ce contexte le
gouvernement accompagne les français et
notamment les agents publics en effet le
Ministre de la Fonction publique a
annoncé différentes mesures pour
préserver le pouvoir d'achat de tous les
fonctionnaires avec des mesures ciblées
en particulier sur les agents de
catégorie B et C et c'est une enveloppe
de 25 millions d'euros qui a été ouverte
pour compenser ces revalorisations
salariales annoncées en juin 2023 cette
enveloppe de 215 millions d'euros
permettra de couvrir au moins 50 % vous
en avez parlé monsieur le Président des
surcûts liés aux mesures de point
d'indice pour tous les établissements
mais aussi d'apporter des soutiens plus
ciblés pour les plus
fragilisés le knous et les CROUS comme
en 2022 comme en 2023 feront quant à eux
l'objet d'une compensation intégrale de
ces mesures salariales aussi pour
2024 les établissements sont appelés
pour le reste à un effort exceptionnel
contte tenu de leur réserve financière
la situation en effet financière de nos
établissements qui affiche des niveaux
de fond de roulement de trésorerie
disponi important en croissance depuis
plusieurs années doit leur permettre
cette année d'abord d'absorber cet
effort pour
2024 ces réserves disponibles sont
estimé à environ 1 milliard d'euros pour
les établissements d'enseignement
supérieur et de recherche et 300
millions d'euros pour les organismes de
recherche soit un niveau très supérieur
à l'effort exceptionnel qui leurit
demandé je parle bien d'ici de réserves
financières qui sont d'après les données
transmises par les établissements
d'après une enquête que l'on a fait
libre de tout emploi cela exclut en
particulier les investissements qu'il
soit déjà engagé ou simplement programmé
par les votes en conseil
d'administration des
établissements c'est pourquoi j'ai
demandé aux établissements de mobiliser
leurs réservve mais de le faire sans
renoncer au projet en cours je tiens à
vous assurer comme je l'ai fait devant
les présidents d'université et comme je
l'ai fait à l'Assemblée nationale que
nous serons attentifs aux situations
particulières liées à un paysage
hétérogène au niveau des établissements
le choix a été fait de compenser à 50 %
l'ensemble des établissements pour 2024
pour se garder les marges nécessaires
pour apporter des soutiens
supplémentaires aux établissements qui
qui serait dans une situation critique
un point sur les dotations
d'investissement qui sont en hausse dans
ce budget pour 2024 en effet les
contrats de plan État-région se
déploient pour rappel ce sont 1,2
milliards d'euros pour les
établissements du ministère de
l'Enseignement supérieur et de la
recherche sur la période
2021-2027 et les projets continuent leur
montée en charge l'an prochain les
établissements de l'ESR bénéficieront de
la de 600 millions d'euros de
l'enveloppe
interministérielle consacré à la
rénovation des bâtiments de l'État
enveloppe annoncé par la première
ministre nous allonsons des financements
spécifiques pour des projets
emblématiques comme le campus hospitalo
universitaire à saint-toin ou encore le
Paris santé campus sur le site du valde
grâce ou encore le Centre national de la
matière extraterrestre sur le site du
Jardin des Plantes enfin en dehors de la
mission recherche et enseignement
supérieur les établissements de mon
ministère continueront également de
bénéficier de financements extra
buudgétaires importants ceux qui sont
liés en particulier au financement de
France
2030 mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
les grands défis que notre pays doit
relever restent non seulement les mêmes
mais très importants ils sont
écologiques technologiques industriels
et sociétaux
pour y faire face les contributions de
l'Enseignement supérieur et de la
recherche sont essentielles la France
doit donc demeurer cette grande nation
scientifique qui découvre mais qui forme
aussi au métiers d'aujourd'hui et de
demain qui innove qui attire les talents
dans un paysage international complexe
mouvant et compétitif le budget pour
2024 de mon ministère répond à cela de
façon responsable en respectant les
engagements pris et en permettant de
relever les défis qui nous attendent je
vous remercie merci madame la ministre
sans plus tarder je vais donner la
parole à nos deux rapporteur budgétaire
pour une première série de questions je
ne sais pas qui qui commence si c'est
Laurence Garnier pour les recherches ou
Stéphane piénoir pour l'enseignement
supérieur très bien merci monsieur le
Président merci madame la ministre pour
ces éléments donc comme l'a indiqué le
président Lafond tout à l'heure je
prends la suite de ma collègue Lord
D'cos sur sur ce ces crédits alloués à
la recherche et vous me permettrez d'en
profiter pour la saluer et la remercier
pour le travail qu'elle a
réalisé suite à votre intervention
j'aimerais madame la ministre vous poser
quelques questions en commençant par les
conséquences du rapport gilet qui vous a
été remis au mois de juillet dernier et
qui pourrait en fonction des suites que
vous lui donnerez constituer un tournant
majeur dans la structuration de
l'écosystème de la recherche
française suite à la remise de ce
rapport
et dans la ligne de ces préconisations
le gouvernement a semble-t-il décidé de
donner à différents organismes de
recherche un nouveau rôle d'agence de
programme c'est un élément d'évolution
majeur qui m'amène à vous poser un
certain nombre de questions d'abord
avez-vous tiré un bilan de l'activité
des alliances de recherche telles
qu'elles existent
aujourd'hui pensez-vous que nos
organismes nationaux de recherche puisse
parvenir à exercer cette fonction
d'agence de programme en plus de leur
fonction d'opérateur de recherche tel
qu'il l'exerce
actuellement comment voyez-vous le rôle
de ces agences de programme par rapport
aux alliances euh que j'ai évoqué à
l'instant quelle sera la place des
sciences humaines et sociales dans cette
nouvelle
organisation et puis enfin quel sera
l'impact de cette réorganisation dont
nous connaîtront sans doute les contours
de manière plus précise dans les
semaines à venir euh en terme budgétaire
et qu'en est-il de la clause de revoyure
qu'évoquait le président Lafond au début
de son
propos voilà pour cette première partie
de question qui interroge les suites que
vous donnerez budgétaire et en terme de
structuration au rapport gilet
concernant la loi de programmation de la
recherche vous avez évoqué rapidement
dans votre re propos liminaire
l'installation des chair de professeurs
juniors je m'interrogais sur les raisons
qui rendent compliqué l'atteintre des
objectifs en terme de nombre objectifs
fixés par la loi de de
programmation de la recherche et enfin
un dernier point centré plus
spécifiquement sur la recherche
biomédicale puisque ça a été aussi
l'actualité de l'année 2023 avec la
publication du du rapport du Professeur
Alain Fiser président de l'Académie des
sciences qui a été publié au début de
l'année qui évoquait à la fois un
affaiblissement progressif de la
recherche française et qui soulignait
l'état préoccupant de la recherche
médicale française il y a eu ensuite le
rapport de France université et puis
vous avez confié une mission à l'été
dernier je crois sur la rénovation de la
recherche médicale à Raymond Lemoigne et
à Manuel Tunon de Lara est-ce que vous
pouvez nous donner l'état des réflexions
de votre ministère au sujet de la
souveraineté de la France en matière de
recherche biomédicale je vous
remercie Stéphane
pinoir merci monsieur le Président je
vais essayer d'être concis plus concis
qu'à l'habitude puisque j'avais entendu
la la complainte de mes collègues qui me
disaient que j'avais pris toutes les
questions dans lors des auditions
précédentes donc je vais tâcher d'en
laisser quelques-unes à leur disposition
je vais commencer par saluer d'abord
évidemment un budget globalement en
hausse sur les crédits enseignement
supérieur et la vie étudiante environ un
demiilliard d'euros tout de même donc ça
n'est pas rien je voulais commencer par
ça mais donc j'aurai quatre points à
évoquer premier point il porte sur les
les critères d'attribution de calcul des
crédits qui sont alloués à la fois au
cru et aux Espig alors sont deux sujets
on va dire totalement différentes ceci
près qu'il touche la vie estudiantine de
toute façon euh de lignes budgétaires
différentes avec une même problématique
l'absence de critères qui prenant en
compte la la fréquentation et et et et
on sait que cette ces fréquentations
sont en en hausse pour les ESPI vous
connaissez j'allis dire mon combat en
tout cas mon mon Modot d'or depuis
plusieurs années désormais avec une un
nombre d'étudiants en forte augmentation
et une dotation pour charge de service
public qui est à hauteur qui est qui est
à 5 % environ euh de ce que coûte un
étudiant dans l'enseignement supérieur
environ 600 600 € avec de fortes
disparités c'est un quelque chose qui
est réclamé et puis pour les cru là
aussi une forte augmentation avec
différents différents critères
différents paramètres qui rentrre en jeu
bien sûr la loi des la loi lesvi pour
avoir des contractualisations plus
proches des lieux de d'étude le repas 1
€ mais qui est compensé le repas et et
même sur les repas à tarifs classiques
j'ai envie dire une augmentation très
sensible notamment depuis le covid donc
une révision de ces critères globalement
est-elle envisagée pour quelque chose
qui soit assez assez transparent assez
lisible deuxème interrogation sur vous
l'avez dit la compensation des mesures
salariales dites les les mesures guini à
hauteur de 50 % vous l'avez dit pour
pour cette
année c'est c'est une bonne chose mais
vous savez que pour les établissements
d'enseignement supérieur ça représente
environ 150 millions d'euros qu'elles
doivent financer ça alors sur leur fonds
propres sur leur fond de réserve leur
fond de roulement appelle ça comme on
veut j'allais dire on l'évalue aussi
comme on veut puisque la fourchetteê
entre 600 millions et 1 milliard c'est
c'est toujours selon les syndicats et la
police pas le même problème mais on voit
bien 150 millions chaque année avec un
fond de réserve qui est de l'ordre de
entre on va faire couper la poire en de
750 millions on a quelques années
seulement dev vant nous donc tout en
sachant que les engagements n'engagent
que ceux qui les reçoivent est-ce que
vous pouvez vous engager à ce que cette
compensation soit intégrale à partir de
l'année prochaine 3ème point alors ça
c'est un une problématique nous qui est
apparue cette année c'est la plateforme
Solta pour vous savez c'est la nouvelle
plateforme de collecte et de versement
du solde de la taxe d'apprentissage
c'est une nouveauté lancée en en 2023 et
au dire de plusieurs responsables
d'établissement que j'ai auditionné
pendant la préparation de ce ce budget
de cet avis je cite c'est une
catastrophe industrielle voil l'urais
pas moi je ne l'aurais pas dit vous le
savez de manière aussi brutale mais mais
fin août on nous a fait part
de d'environ 20 % du solde de cette taxe
d'apprentissage versée sur les les
comptes des des universités des
établissements d'enseignement supérieur
alors que habituellement fin août tout
est réglé et on a touché environ 80 %.
je sais que les choses sont en train de
se se consolider mais néanmoins les
budgets ont été construits donc sur une
une forte incertitude et j'ai perçu
vraiment des une inquiétude de la part
des des acteurs pour la première fois de
plus il va rester une un fond libre car
car les entreprises n'ont pas été euh en
capacité de déterminer euh facilement
leur versement sur la plateforme en
raison de de difficultés techniquequ de
lisibilité est-ce que vous pouvez nous
indiquer les modalités d'attribution de
ce fond libre et quelles mesures vont
être prise pour éviter les mêmes
difficultés l'an prochain et 4e et
dernier point euh il me semble c'est un
peu moins budgétaire mais il me semble
important de mettre en place assez
rapidement une une labellisation et une
accréditation par l'état des nouvelles
formations qui sont proposé dans
l'enseignement supérieur notre
commission vous savez a organisé une
table ronde il y a quelques semaines sur
l'enseignement privé et nous avons vu
combien des des officines en réalité
prennent un secteur proposent des
formations à la fois non reconnues par
l'État et non contrôlé en terme de
qualité investissent des champs de
formation à l'absence d'alternative et
et prennent les les crédit ad hoc est-ce
qu'il est possible de plutôt favoriser
des labalisations des accréditations
pour des établissements d'enseignement
reconnus par l'État et notamment par les
expiqués merci madame la ministre je
vais vous laisser répondre à cette
première série de
questions merci beaucoup monsieur le
Président merci beaucoup pour ces
questions que je vais prendre dans
l'ordre parce qu'elles sont toutes
différentes alors peut-être de façon
group enfin pour rejoindre les question
aussi de monsieur le Président répondre
sur le schéma d'emploi vous m'aviez
interrogé qui est lié à la LPR et qui
rejoint aussi votre question madame la
sénatrice sur la CPJ un petit peu pour
avoir donc pour 2000 alors aujourd'hui
effectivement il y a eu un une
difficulté au démarrage on va dire non
seulement de déploiement avec le covid
l'acceptabilité la mise en œuvre au
départ mais pour
2023 même si les données sont pas encore
complètement consolidées et connues à et
qu'il faut rester prudent puisque nous
ne sommes pas à la fin de l'année la
situation euh aujourd'hui atterri et les
je dirais que les schémas d'emploi sont
réalisés euh il a été réalisé en 2022
avec +
474 ETP supplémentaires les schémas
votés en PLF euh respectent
laalpr les mesures emblématiques comme
les contrats doctoraux et la CPJ dont
j'ai parlé doivent respecter ce le
schéma d'emploi prévu et le déploiement
du CES schéma d'emploi et donc nous
rentrons je dirais depuis fin 2022 mais
en 2023 dans une phase de régime
permanent qui permet d'appliquer euh la
mise en œuvre de ces postes
supplémentaires euh la hausse de
l'emploi scientifique devrait donc se
voir comme elle était prévue et suivant
le nombre d'emplois qui qui se déploie
donc effectivement en 2024 nous
prévoyons 650 TP au niveau LPR 725 au
total avec les postes supplémentaires
pour le CEA et euh l'objectif des euh
5200 ETP supplémentaire prévu entre 2021
et 2030 devra tenu sur le redéploiement
des difficultés initiales qu'il y a eu
donc pour 2024 juste pour vous donner
ces 200 CPJ qui sont prévu ça été 177 en
2023 et 340 contrats doctoraux en plus
c'est-à-dire que depuis 2020 on aura
augmenté de à peu près 1100 contrats
doctoraux supplémentaires sur la
trajectoire de la LPR et nous allons
continuer à la suivre comme prévu donc
effectivement on a eu une sous exécution
pardon en 2022 qui était en particulier
du visible au niveau des organismes
nationaux de recherche avec à peu près -
27 ETP cette situation a été identifiée
pour tout vous dire en particulier au
CNRS à Line Rae et aujourd'hui cela
rentre dans l'ordre ça devrait être une
situation exceptionnelle et nous aidons
pour le déploiement des emplois prévus
aussi bien dans les organismes que dans
les établissements voilà pour le point
emploi c'est un point qu'on avait vu
l'année dernière aussi donc que je me
permets de faire un peu complet alors
sur la partie rapport gilet je vais pas
vous dévoiler des annonces qui
effectivement seront probablement faites
dans les semaines à venir mais en
partant en tout cas du rapport gilet et
du travail qui a été fait avec les
organismes et avec les universités en
particulier France université et U0 euh
ce rôle d'agence de programme
complémentaire puisque vous avez des
opérateurs de recherche qui sont les
établissements et les organismes et en
plus nous leur proposons de coordonner
ces agences de programme l'idée de ces
agences de programme c'est vraiment de
coordonner les acteurs sur une
thématique donnée acteurs que ce soi les
autres organismes petits ou grands ou
bien les établissements d'enseignement
supérieur c'est un rôle de coordination
euh qui et vous l'avez très bien
identifié finalement remplaceront si
elles
sont effectivement annoncé les alliances
en leur formalisant leur rôle avec une
lettre de mission donc on ne touchera
pas au statut voilà des onr c'est des
opérateurs de recherche mais c'est
vraiment en remplacement des alliances
par effectivement à cette occasion et
dans la gouvernance simple et légère
proposée un bilan où en tout cas la le
travail avec les alliances doit être
fait et le lien doit être fait donc
c'est un travail dans cette premier
année expérimentale que nous aurons et
que nous connaissons puisque tous les
acteurs participai à ces alliances comme
je vous l'ai dit ce sont des agences de
programme sur des thématiques et donc
par rapport à votre question sur le rôle
des SHS c'est pour nous les sciences
humaines et sociales sont des
disciplines qui doivent avoir une
stratégie particulière donc nous avons
une réflexion particulière sur ce
domaine mais ça ne fera pas part de
d'agences de programme qui sont plutôt
liées sur des thématiques comme par
exemple l'énergie et pas sur la physique
ou les mathématiques nous avons des
agences de programme qui sont là pour
finalement mettre les acteurs autour de
la table pour relever des défis
thématiques des grands défis de société
et pas pour guider des stratégies de
discipline donc c'est une réflexion que
nous avons sur les sciences humaines et
sociales mais je dirais en parallèle des
agences de programme alors sur l'impact
en terme de budget et l'impact global
sans dévoiler je dirais vous avez parler
de de de tâche en plus oui dans le sens
que nous allons formaliser les missions
que nous allons formaliser les choses
mais quelque part c'est l'avantage c'est
que nous travaillons déjà beaucoup plus
et nous allons continuer en
interministériel parce que une de ces
caractéristiqu de de ces agences c'est
de jouer équipe France avec les acteurs
de la recherche mais aussi au niveau
interministériel donc elles seront
portées par plusieurs ministères aussi
ça c'est important et quelque part quand
vous avez les PEPR les programmes
d'équipement prioritaire de recherche
aujourd'hui qui sont pilotés par un ou
des onr finalement ce sont les projets
scientifiques qui auraient pu être si on
avait créé les agences de programme
avant ben la conséquence de projets
scientifiques pilotés par les agences
donc vous le voyez finalement on
formalise quelque chose qui est de
comment traiter des grands défis avec
l'ensemble des forces au niveau national
avec l'ensemble des acteurs finalement
les projets c'est déjà illustré dans
France 2030 par des PEPR et l'idée c'est
de tirer aussi une expérience de ce que
l'on a fait dans les PEPR pour mieux
dimensionner les agences et en tout cas
au niveau de cette force de coordination
nous allons regarder les problèmes de
moyens pour accompagner la création de
ces agences de programme au niveau de la
coordination donc voilà pour vous donner
sans déflorer les annonces faites
quelques quelques réponses P qui
j'espère répondre à vos questions euh
sur la clause de revoyure LPR qui est
aussi une question commune donc comme je
vous l'ai dit nous prévoyons de revenir
vers vous plutôt en tout début d'année
2024 avec en première partie un bilan
puisqueavant une revoyure il faut faire
un bilan de la LPR un bilan que je
souhaite faire par rapport à toutes les
les les les impacts de toutes les effets
en particulier ressources humaines mais
aussi ANR euh de la LPR et que je
souhaite repositionner dans un contexte
européen et international donc nous
avons déjà fait ce travail en interne
mais d'où la sollicitation probablement
le travail aussi qu'on souhaite faire
avec l'OPEX mais aussi avec l'OCDE qui a
des données au niveau européen euh voire
international pour pouvoir vous
présenter un positionnement au niveau
européen international ce bilan est en
fait il est clair que dans cette LPR il
y a cet article finalement de de
revoyure alors sans attend je voulais je
voudrais revenir sur quelques points sur
la LPR c'est nous avons essayé de de
tenir compte on va dire de l'inflation
non seulement à travers ben des mesures
comme les mesures guirini sur les agents
publics c'est-à-dire sur les salaires
mais aussi par exemple même sans être
une revoyure LPR j'ai élargi les
contrats doctoraux les réhaussements du
contrat doctoraux non seulement au FL
plus mais aussi au stock des doctorants
l'année dernière en janvier puisque la
apr ne concernait que les nouveaux
doctorants rentrant et donc pour
l'ensemble des doctorants il aurait
fallu attendre 2027 pour voir l'ensemble
des doctorants pouvoir profiter donc
nous avons élargi l'année dernière à
l'ensemble des doctorants ces mesures
LPR nous avons aussi pris des mesures
sur les AAS sur la revalorisation
mesures qui avaient déjà été prises dans
la LPR mais nous avons revalorisé la
prime accompagnant les enseignants du
supérieur avec 50 millions d'euros
supplémentaires au niveau euh de
l'accompagnement LPR donc une réflexion
qui est en cours et que nous viendrons
aussi vous présenter au moment du bilan
en début d'année 2024 au niveau de ces
commissions peut-être sur les CPJ un
petit point particulier parce que vous
m'avez euh euh sur ces objectifs fixés
donc encore une fois elle se déploie
aujourd'hui par rapport au nombre qui
avaiit été fixé dans la le déploiement
de la LPR euh ce sont sur cette loi de
programmation recherche plus de à peu
près 1 milliard 3 supplémentaires qui
ont été investis sur ces ces dispositifs
je voudrais simplement donner un premier
bilan qui me paraît intéressant c'est
que ce dispositif de chair de professeur
junior connaît un véritable succès
puisque il y a eu près de 1000 candidats
pour 229 chair ouvertees en
2021-2022 donc avant de prendre ce
régime permanent de l' ensemble des
postes déployés 1000 pour
229 et sur le bilan de ces deux
premières campagnes c'est 49 % des
lauréat qui reviennent de l'étranger sur
ces chaires chaires je vous rappelle
sont environnés et qui donnent lieu au
bout d'une période de contractualisation
un poste de professeur ou de directeur
de recherche c'est à peu près pour
comparer au au poste de professeur
classique c'est maximum entre 10 et 15 %
de nos postes professeur classique où
l'on voit arriver des de l'étranger des
chercheurs de l'étranger donc on voit
que c'est c'est c'est cher de professeur
junior avec 49 % de lauréa étranger
c'est quelque chose qui améliore
l'attractivité de nos postes et qu'il
faut qu'on continue à je dirais à
accompagner à dans l'environnement des
postes plus classiques et pour
l'évolution de carrière aussi de
l'ensemble de nos collègues donc ne pas
oublier le principe de repyramide d'â et
de reconnaissance de toutes les missions
qui sont pour les missions en
particulier je pense aux enseignants
chercheurs voilà donc je voulais le dire
c'est sont des postees nouveau à mon
avis qu'il faut cadrer qu'il faut
accompagner sans oublier le reste et
c'est un travail qui est en cours mais
qui a aujourd'hui les premiers bilans
donnent des des des des des des
avantages
d'attractivité sur la recherche
biomédicale donc effectivement je
reviens pas sur les bilans que vous avez
fait nous avons une mission alors ce
n'est plus Raymond le Moigne parce qu'il
est devenu directeur de cabinet
d'Aurélien Rousseau c'est Anne-Marie
armandterrasse qui l'a remplacé avec
Manuel Tunon de Lara cette mission a
donc pris un peu de retard puisque avec
les nominations euh nous avions
effectivement on l'avait lancé avec
François brun avant l'été mais elle a
démarré je dirais début octobre nous
allons faire un point d'étape et
effectivement l'idée c'est vraiment de
de donner sur la recherche
biomédicale l'ensemble d'attractivité
des carrières puup nous avons annoncé
déjà avec Aurélien Rousseau des mesures
he sur les retraites mais d'avoir aussi
ce bilan en se positionnant par rapport
à l'Europe à l'international euh et de
regarder comment ce qui est fait et la
la le plan sur le le le biomédical
innovation santé de France 2030 va être
impacté je vous rappelle la création des
bioclusters je vous rappelle la création
des ihchu supplémentaires euh qui sont
quand même une force de frappe sur la
recherche biomédical certaine et donc le
lien entre la recherche fondamentale
jusqu'à la recherche clinique avec les
hôpitaux le rôle de l'ensemble des
acteurs aussi bien institutionnels que
dans les laboratoires ou dans les
hôpitaux et comment développer pour
gagner cette souveraineté enfin regagner
ou repositionner avec en particulier les
7 milliards mis pour le plan innovation
santé qui a une partie sur la recherche
et innovation et une partie sur le
développement des marchés de l'industrie
donc c'est ce cette mission là qui va
être gardée sur des volets beaucoup plus
larges qu'uniquement le plan innovation
santé voilà je pense avoir fait le tour
sur monsieur le sénateur Piednoir donc
effectivement je reviendrai pas sur ce
que j'ai dit dans la la présentation
mais sur la les révisions des critères
ou en tout cas la prise en compte des
critères à la fois sur le CR vie
étudiante donc je je je c'est vrai que
il y a une attention particulière de la
part de ma part et de la part de mon
ministère sur la vie étudiante je crois
que ça se voit dans ce budget parce
qu'il y en a besoin il y a eu cette
première étape des bourses accompagné de
cette enveloppe du demi-milliard avec la
restauration et tous les déploiements
pour avoir l'accès à la restauration
nous avons un plan logement et nous
accompagnons le cru pour la compensation
lorsque nous prenons des mesures le cru
est compensé complètement sur les
mesures salariales 2022 2023 2024 sur
les surcûts énergétiques aussi donc il y
a il y a effectivement une attention
particulière les révisions des critères
ça va être en particulier d'une part la
remise à plat complet du modèle des
bourses sur critères sociaux donc pour
répondre aussi à monsieur le Président
sur ce calendrier nous avons la première
étape qui démarre là les les étudiants
voient déjà sur leur compte en banque
l'effet de cette première étape et nous
continuons à travailler avec le
ministère des Solidar
pour avoir un modèle de bourse vraiment
remis à plat parce que ce modèle n'est
plus représentatif et on veut toucher
ceux qui on ont le plus besoin donc la
philosophie c'est aider mieux eter plus
ceux qui en ont le plus besoin pour
permettre d'avoir des meilleures
conditions d'études à tous nos étudiants
et donc de revoir ce modèle de bourse
par rapport à leur périmètre comme nous
l'avons déjà fait là en rentrant des
étudiants qui se retrouvaient toujours à
à ne pas être boursi alors que que voilà
il se retrouve en difficulté c'est pour
ça que nous avons pas appliqué un
pourcentage d'augmentation aux échelons
de bourse mais une somme de 37 € qui
correspond à 6 % de l'augmentation du
plus fort échelon donc c'est une vraie
philosophie une vraie politique que nous
avons appliqué et aussi bien sur la le
côté profil territorial nous avons
augmenté les montants de bourse de 30 €
par mois supplémentaires pour les
étudiants qui étudient en outreem donc
on tient compte déjà dans cette première
étape d'une certaine territorialisation
des profils des étudiants et aussi les
quatre points supplémentaires pour les
étudiants en situation de handicap et
les aidanss là aussi on tient compte d'
un profil particulier des étudiants donc
on voit que dans cette première étape ce
n'est pas juste une revalorisation mais
ça vous donne des pistes de sur
lesquelles nous travaillons pour la
remise à plat du modèle de bourse qui
devrait se faire au plus tard pour la
rentrée 2025 puisqu'il faut être prêt en
mars 2020 5 pour l'ouverture de la
plateforme c'est-à-dire il faut qu'en
gros le modèle de Bour soit prêt à Noël
ou en tout début d'année 2025 donc vous
le voyez ça serait trop difficile de le
faire pour cette année à Noël enfin fin
2023 début 2024 d'autant plus que nous
voulons être cohérents avec l'évolution
de la de du ministère des solidarités de
du travail du ministère des solidarités
sur la solidarité à la source et pouvoir
avoir des références budgétaires
communes pour pouvoir finalement avoir
une vision globale des aides sociales
aussi pour nos jeunes et
particulièrement pour nos étudiants donc
nous travaillons avec le ministère des
solidarités pour fixer ces critères la
référence budgétaire et cetera au niveau
de du budget pris en compte pour pouvoir
établir ce nouveau modèle des bourses
dans ce calendrier pour les Espig vous
le savez c'est quelque chose que l'on
suit pour ce les les je je répète pas à
peu près la la subvention de 600 € dont
vous avez parlé c'est un modèle
économique effectivement avec un poids
limité très limité des subventions de
l'État puisque ce modèle économique dans
leur recette c'est 5 à 10 % suivant les
cas au niveau maximum au niveau des des
des subventions pour chargge de service
public euh c'est contrairement aux
établissements publics d'enseignement
supérieur relevant du MESR ce sont
beaucoup les droits d'inscription qui
font partie de ce modèle dans ces
établissements les ESP disposent
notamment de la possibilité notamment de
jouer sur ces droits d'inscription ou
d'avoir cette liberté d'avoir un modèle
économique plus souple que au niveau des
des établissement d'enseignement
supérieur pour autant sur le PLF 2023
nous avions augmenté d'un million
d'euros par rapport à au PLF enfin en
tout cas aux subventions de 2022 pour
tenir compte de cette augmentation
d'étudiants pour tenir compte aussi du
lien que l'on avait fortement de la
reconnaissance de ces 11 Espig dont les
effectifs ont augmenté et donc
évidemment nous maintenons et nous
continuerons à accompagner ces
établissements d'enseignement
aussi sur je tourne alors sur
soltea tu as
la hop je dois
l'avir
hop là
voilà alors sur cette plateforme donc
évidem effectivement comme vous l'avez
dit cette plateforme est nouvelle cette
année a été installée pour en fait de
deux choses l'idée était de rendre
possible de voir à peu près de de de le
lien avec les établissements et les
industriels c'était le but de pouvoir
avoir un accès direct sur une plateforme
faciliter la collecte effectivement de
cette taxe d'apprentissage bon j'y
reviens pas cette année 2023 c'est la
première année de fonctionnement elle
est gérée par la Caisse des dépôts et
des consinuations cette plateforme
effectivement des dysfonctionnements
vous l'avez dit sont apparus alors ce
que ce qui a été fait pour ces
dysfonctionnements de première année
c'est qu'à chaque fois l'État a tout
fait pour y remédier en temps réel en
suivant euh c'est un travail d'évolution
constante qui a eu lieu et nous sommes
en train de faire un retour d'expérience
forte de cette première année de
campagne 2023 utilisant la plateforme je
peux vous dire qu'à date parce que nous
suivons cela et nous sommes conscients
des difficultés difficultés des
établissements et des industriels il y a
les deux côtés et donc à date il y a
quand même eu un un suivi un effort
particulier puisque un équivalent de 72
% des montants attribués en 2022 en
moyenne ont été affectés donc nous avons
rattrapé le retard un peu depuis cet été
en essayant d'accompagner alors que la
campagne n'est pas terminée euh je peux
vous dire que les établissements
pourront dès l'année prochaine vu le
retour qu'on est en train de faire avoir
beaucoup plusut tôt cette visibilité
dont vous parlez pour préparer les
budgets sur les fonds allués le lien
renforcer le lien entre les état
éblissements et les industriels et les
contrôles contre les fraudes puisqueun
des gros problèmes qu'il y a eu autour
de l'été c'est des fraudes à travers
cette plateforme qui a dû bloquer la
plateforme pendant un certain temps pour
pouvoir résoudre ce problème donc nous
en sommes conscien des difficultés de
l'évolution que doit avoir cette
plateforme et mon ministère y travaille
avec les établissements et les
industriels pour que l'année prochaine
ça soit beaucoup plus fluide voilà sur
l'accréditation
des nouvelles formations privées alors
vous le savez j'ai fait une annonce lors
de
mon discours de
rentré effectivement nous avons un bilan
par rapport aux problématiques de
transparence de certaines formations
privées par rapport à des fraudes ou des
non transparences d'affichage de frais
d'inscription ou autres ou alors par
rapport à un non cohérence par rapport à
des étudiants de formation initiale de
jeunes étudiants en formation initiale
donc nous avons annoncé nous travaillons
avec le ministère du Travail pour
améliorer ou renforcer des labels
existants et nous travaillons avec des
familles et des étudiants avec des
critères de transparence qui seront
affichés pour que les familles et les
étudiants et ça s'adresse plutôt aux
élèves qui vont passer étudiant
c'est-à-dire formation initiale jeune
étudiant avec des formations qui doivent
assurer de l'accompagnement étudiant une
gouvernance table un affichage des prix
d'inscription des des condition
d'inscription donc nous listons
actuellement des critères qui seront
vérifiés qui seront affichés et qui
seront associés à un label peut-être pas
supplémentaire mais renforcé pour
pouvoir avoir des informations aux
familles et à tous nos étudiants donc
c'est quelque chose sur lequel on s'est
engagé et nous sommes en train d'y
travailler ça sera à court
terme merci sur sur la réforme des
bourses est-ce que vous aurez besoin
d'une d'une loi pour modifier sur la
réforme des bourses proprement non
puisque c'est un réforme de modèle des
bourses et donc ça n'est pas du registre
législatif par rapport à à une loi sur
la réforme des
bourses alors je vais prendre toutes vos
questions en vous invitant à chaque fois
à bien regarder le le compteur c'est une
indication toujours intéressante pour
formuler ces questions je commencer
Paran
chanrel merci monsieur le Président
Madame la Ministre bon il y a déjà
beaucoup de sujets bien évidemment qui
ont été aborder donc je vais en aborder
un seul pour en laisser d'autres aussi à
à mes collègues c'est plus
particulièrement justement sur la
question des bourses que vous avez
évoqué assez longuement bon pas besoin
de revenir dessus vous savez très bien
le niveau de précarité étudiante on
estime à 27 % environ d'étudiantes et
étudiants qui vivent qui vivraient sous
le seuil de de de pauvreté comme vous
l'aveaz dit il y a urgence à répondre à
cette à cette précarité donc à court
terme est-ce qu'on connaît euh l'impact
des mesures prises pour en cette rentrée
2023 justement parce que vous aviez
annoncé 35000 étudiants boursiers en
plus et 140000 étudiants passants à
l'échelon supérieur où en est-on
concrètement réellement par rapport à ce
qui avait été annoncé et à plus long
terme alors ça a été ébauché mais il y a
deux proposition de de réforme
actuellement qui qui circulle du système
de de Bours sur critères sociaux qui ont
été posé ces dernières semaines vous
avez une qui est systémique qui a été
d'ailleurs le fait d'une tribune au
Monde de 14 présidents et président
d'université sous la forme d'une
allocation d'études fondée sur sur
l'idée justement de de contrat avec les
étudiants et inspirer un peu du modèle
danois c'est une allocation qui qui
permettrait justement d'offrir la
garantie d'un d'un revenu décent à tous
les les les étudiantes et étudiants euh
et favoriserait donc le le leur
autonomie et il y en a une deuxième qui
elle est une réforme paramétrique qui
est proposée notamment par le rapport
jolon où justement avec pour piste
principale c'est la généralisation d'une
prime universelle de rentrée de 500 € la
suppression des gesselons en faveur d'un
mécanisme progressif sans rupture
indexation du barem via un mécanisme
identique aux aide sociale et un
changement de revenus utilisé pour les
le calcul des bourses afin de de juste
privilégier le revenu fiscal de
référence en fait ma question est très
simple entre ces deux options quelle
option aurait votre votre faveur Jean
ingret bien merci monsieur le Président
tout d'abord saluer et remercier nos
rapporteurs qui nous ont quand même
laissé quelques miettes en terme de de
question saluer naturellement notre
ministre beaucoup de ministres se
présentent devant nous dans les les
différentes commissions du Sénat en
souhaitant ou en voulant nous faire
croire que leur budget augmente mais en
tout cas force de constater madame la
ministre votre pugnacité à avoir une
augmentation sensible de des budgets de
l'enseignement supérieur en tout cas moi
je je salue votre travail euh je pense
qu'il y a pas eu de choc pour
l'université depuis Valérie pcré et la
réforme de l'autonomie des universités
donc en tout cas voilà c'est
enthousiasment et ça fait du bien même
si Yan Chantrel le disait il y a
quelques instants et encore beaucoup à
faire pour les étudiants qui vivent dans
la précarité permettez-moi d'associer
dans ma première question Pierre-Antoine
levvi concernant la loi que nous avons
fait nous avons fait voter il y a il y a
quelques quelques semaines quelques mois
concernant la restauration des étudiants
vous avez eu 25 millions pour cette
année concernant le le budget en 2023
nous espérons 25 millions d'euros
supplémentaires l'année prochaine est-ce
que c'est ces 25 millions en tout cas on
espère qu'il ne se feront pas au
détriment des projets que vous avez
lancé des amélioration des améliorations
sensibles les différents budgets que
vous avez pu égrainer
mais quel est le timing des décrets
d'application de cette loi peut-on
espérer aussi passer dans les hypothèses
de travail de de trois repas à cinq
repas comme nous le souhaitons avec avec
Pierre-Antoine pour quand même avoir une
assise du nombre de repas assez
suffisante pour pour étudiants c'est ma
première question notre première
question deuxème question il y a eu
beaucoup de dégradation dans les
université ces dernières semaines suite
à différents conflits internationaux qui
se aussi se reflète sur la vie de de nos
universités pardon en France et avec
parfois plusieurs centaines de de
milliers d'euros de de dégradation
est-ce que ces dégradations vont peser
sur le budget de l'université ou est-ce
que les étudiants qui ont parfois
saccagé certains lieux seront punis et
via parfois des systèmes d'assurance ou
autres seront intégrés dans le système
de de réparation de ces dégradations
avec aussi votre rôle madame la ministre
concernant en tant que prés en tant que
ministre l'enseignement supérieur votre
rôle par rapport au président
d'université qui dans l'ensemble ont
plutôt bien répondu mais encore un ou
deux
récalcitran qui font parfois preuve de
l'acheter par rapport à à des actes et
donc dans les 15 secondes qu'il me reste
vous posez une question sur la
réaffirmation des valeurs de la
République avec les difficultés que nous
connaissons actuellement et depuis
quelques semaines comment peut-on
réaffirmer nos valeurs républicaines en
ces temps difficile
merci Lord
Arcos qui fait qui fait mieux merci
monsieur le Président alors moi j'ai
trois
questions d'abord merci enfin une c'est
pas une question c'est une remarque mais
merci à ma chère collègue Laurent
Garnier d'ailleurs que je suis très
touché par par ton petit mot je sais que
le rapport de la recherche sera bien
évidemment bien bien défendu euh enfin
en tout cas notre notre rapport notre
avis euh d'avoir reparlé de la de de de
la biosanté
euh moi j'ai fait une une note sur
l'innovation thérapeutique en oncologie
euh en avec l'OPEX et en effet euh
certains chercheurs ne peuvent pas finir
leurs essai cliniques et on sait très
bien Madame la minist que ça n'est pas
forcément euh votre responsabilité c'est
qu'il faudrait bien évidemment que dans
la mission santé il puisse avoir aussi
un fléchage recherche et c'est vrai que
là-dessus je me suis battu pendant
plusieurs années là-dessus et je je
partage ça en tout cas avec vous parce
que tout ne doit pas être forcément posé
sur vos épaules deux questions on
parlait de la loi programmation
recherche on a beaucoup parlé des cher
junior il faut rappeler aussi que les
décrets d'application ont mis un an et
demi à venir donc c'est aussi ça qui a
ralenti l'application
l'application de de de cette mesure
qu'en est-il des CDI de mission qui ont
eu beaucoup de mal à démarrer est-ce que
finalement d'ailleurs elles ont vraiment
démarré ils ont vraiment démarré et
savoir si finalement ça a été abandonné
dans dans dans le voilà dans dans
l'esprit de la loi et puis je voulais
revenir une dernière fois je va dire une
dernière fois j'espère pour vous une
dernière fois sur les logements
étudiants qui vont être réquisitionnés
pour les Jos et j'aimerais que vous
puissiez relarifier votre position que
j'ai déjà entendu plusieurs fois mais il
reste encore une polémique euh lattente
et donc voilà euh 1h 1 minute 13
j'ai pierre
ouyas merci monsieur le Président merci
madame la ministre pour la qualité de
votre discours moi j'aimerais euh
revenir sur les les les trésoreries des
des des universités ce que j'ai du mal à
à comprendre comment alors que les
universités font face à un déficit
structurel elles pourrai amasser des des
trésors de guerre de cette façon je vais
juste prendre un exemple celui de de
l'Université de créteille l'Université
du valdemarne monsieur le monsieur le
Président où les étudiants ont augmenté
de 20 % entre 2017 et 2022 alors que la
subvention pour charge de service public
a elle augmenté que de 8 % donc il y a
un déficit
structurel qui fait que il y a il y a
une baisse du taux d'encadrement et je
remarque le le rapporteur Laurent
Laffond l'avait bien noté c'est un
déficit structurel qui touche
principalement les universités nouvelles
et très souvent de province parce que
elles n'ont jamais eu de de récupération
par rapport à une dotation qui é qui
était euh minorée par par rapport à
celle des des universités plus anciennes
donc pour reprendre le cas de de Créteil
aujourd'hui c'est 10 million d'euros de
déficit ce qui est énorme considérable
et qui fait que l'université va geler
tous ses recrutements pour l'année
prochaine il y aura pas de recrutement
hein ce qui est un signal terrible
envoyé qui veut dire je je le répète que
le taux d'encadrement va baisser que
l'échec en licence va sans doute
augmenter parce que les deux choses sont
sont tout à fait corrélées et de façon
générale aujourd'hui on s'interroge sur
le manque d'intérêt des jeunes pour les
les missions de recherche mais quand il
y a pas de perspective d'embauche et
qu'une université peut geler totalement
son embauche on comprend très bien
pourquoi les jeunes se se détournent de
ce métier alors l'an passé quasiment
dans la même configuration je vous avais
euh un peu alerté
sur la situation de l'université
nantaire et vous aviez trouvé des des
crédits je je me permets de faire
aujourd'hui la même demande pour pour
crateille avec sans doute la même
réussite madame la ministre et je vous
en remercie d'avance c'est déjà fait
vous voyez merci Madame la
Ministre Monique
dearcou je vous remercie madame la
ministre euh donc mais ça a été déjà dit
par mon collègue Yan Chantrel la
précarité étudiant s'installe
durablement même si les efforts sont
fait on peut le reconnaître et on peut
espérer que la prochaine réforme des
bourses que vous n vous en AZ parlé ne
sera pas une éème rustine vous avvez
confié donc une mission et ça a été dit
au professeur jolon sur la condition de
vie et d'étude des réussit des étudiants
le rapport n'a pas été publié sera-il
publié ou peut-être prochainement voilà
donc et vous avez puisé dans ce rapport
donc des mesures pour pasalier cette
année au défaut du système des bourses
par contre accepteriez-vous d'envisager
donc l'instauration d' loocation
d'autonomie universelle d'étude nous
avons déposé le groupe écologiste une
proposition de loi dans ce sens qui sera
débattu le 13 décembre mais j'aimerais
au moins que vous puissiez donc
envisager cette possibilité et la faire
étudier par par vos services de façon à
pouvoir avoir une réponse parce que
c'est une demande quand même qui est
faite par énormément d'associations
étudiantes 14 présidents deuniversité se
sont prononcés dans ce sens
et je souhaite vraiment que il y ait une
réflexion de la part des services de
façon à pouvoir donner une réponse
vraiment intéressante parce que nous
avons eu du mal également et vous allez
le comprendre à chiffrer cette réforme
et dois dire que d'autres pays donc
l'ont mis en œuvre et peut-être que ça
serait envisager comme une autre réforme
qui ne soit pas seulement une réforme
structurelle comme vous avez dit comme
vous voulez remettre à plat le système
des bourses pourquoi pas en discuter
voilà je vous remercie
expression madame ministre d'abord
excusez-moi j'étais petit un peu en
retard je pas écouté vos propos
introductifs difficile d'avoir en même
temps des auditions et des séances dans
l'hémicycle mais on ne peut pas
grand-chose deux questions qui ont trop
budget puis je vais me permettre hors
sujet j'espère ne pas déborder mais je
mutualiserai le temps avec celui laissé
par ma collègue Lord
Arcos le
le le
premier et et et et à la différence de
Pierre julas je ne demanderai rien pour
l'unersité de peau et des pays de
laadour d'abord vous avez beaucoup parlé
de la LPR de son exécution de sa
sous-exécution il y a quand même au-delà
de ces données un chiffre qui est
constant et qui est assez inquiétant
c'est la part de la dépense intérieure
en recherche et développement par
rapport à notre PIB qui est aussi la 2,2
% et pas d'avantage et qui ne qui
n'augmente pas alors que l'Allemagne est
à 3 que la Suède est à
3,5 comment expliquez-vous cette
stagnation de la France qui pourrait
paraître sur le temps long pour un
véritable
décrochage le deuxè question porte sur
la sécurité des étudiants sur les campus
beaucoup d'investissements ont été
réalisés pour assurer la protection des
étudiants des personnels et des biens
Jean ingret vous interrogez déjà dessus
quel bilan dressez-vous des mesures déjà
mis en œuvre des
investissements réalisés pour assurer la
sécurité des étudiants et sont-ils
suffisants et puis mon trème point et je
vais poser des mots plus forts et sortir
du budget après ce qui dit Jean Ingré
moi excusez-moi mais je suis très
choqué apprendre que dans les campus de
mon pays ou du moins dans certains des
étudiants parce qu'ils sont de
confession juives vont en cours la peur
au
ventre des minorités
agissantes menaçantes violentes font ici
et là ré la terreur font l'apologie du
terrorisme et
diffusent un antisémitisme
d'ambiance qui est tout à fait
insupportable
alors je connais l'autonomie des
universités dans cette salle j'ai même
eu l'occasion de la défendre pour vous
et d'avoir un été un peu difficile avec
mon ami
jacquerin pour autant la loi de la
République s'applique partout et c'est
là de votre responsabilité donc quel
bilan quelle mesure plutôt
envisagez-vous de prendre pour lutter
plus efficacement contre le fro des
actes antisémites et contre ceux qui
font l'apologie du terrorisme et qui pr
et qui prolifèr des menaces sur les
étudiants sur les campus sur certains
campus de
France l'auteur de la loi Lévi
Pierre-Antoine lévill en cher en
os merci Monsieur le monsieur le
Président Madame la Ministre moi je
voulais vous remercier euh pour votre
propos liminire et et pour l'implication
que vous avez mis euh pour que cette loi
puisse rentrer en application à
rapidement vous nous aviez promis
qu'elle s'appliquerait pour la rentrée
en tout cas pour le PLF 2024 vous avez
tenu parole Jean Ingré la la souligné
donc je voulais vous remercier euh c'est
25 millions d'euros c'est une première
étape nous
espérons que les crédits 2025- 2026 et
audà puisse évoluer de manière favorable
mais je sais que c'est une discussion
compliquée avec ber mais vous pourrez
compter sur notre soutien je pense pour
convaincre le ministre de l'économie à
lâcher quelques dizaines de millions
pour les étudiants qu' le méritent
puisque la précarité é bien au contraire
continue de gagner du terrain vous le
savez puisque nous sommes les uns et les
autres sollicités par par les étudiants
les associations d'étudiants moi je
voudrais revenir également effectivement
sur le propos de Max Brisson parce que
j'ai été sollicité je crois vous l'avoir
fait remontter par de différents
étudiants plusieurs étudiants qui m'ont
fait part de d'actes antisémite assez
fort sur plusieurs universités de
Toulouse la première celle de Toulouse
Capitol le président a pris acte
rapidement est intervenu immédiatement
pour prendre des sanctions pour dégager
l'idée l'étudiant qui avait proféré des
des propos antisémites il a été localisé
repéré malgré un pseudo et des sanctions
un signalement article 40 a été fait
auprès du Procureur de la République ce
n'est pas le cas de l'université du
Mirail de Toulouse qui est bien connu
pour ces ces tendances islamuchist on
peut le dire aujourd'hui puisque c'est
fait partie des universités qui ont été
dégradées euh plusieurs manifestations
ont été organisées elles ont été
tolérées elles ont été il y a eu des
débordements même si effectivement ça ça
aurait pu ça aurait pu être pire je
voudrais moi vous interroger madame la
ministre savoir si vous comptez
interdire puisque ce sont des
manifestations qui sont interdites sur
le plan
public puisque tous les toutes les
semaines il y en a qui sont interdites
mais dans le domaine deuniversité elles
ne le sont pas il est conseillé de ne
pas de de les interdire mais elles ont
quand même mieux donc je voudrais moi
vous interroger parce que j'ai été
alerté par les présidents d'association
qui sont très inquiets beaucoup ne vont
plus en cours ils ne vont plus en cours
depuis le 7 octobre parce qu'ils ont
peur pour leur sécurité et pour leur
santé j'ai été encore avec le président
de l'Union des étudiants juifs de France
avanthier qui m'a fait part de son
calvaire et et donc c'est c'est vrai que
on peut pas imaginer que en 2023 fin
2023 on puisse avoir peur d'aller en
cours comme c'était le cas il y a il y a
quelques dizaines d'années donc moi je
voudrais que vous preniez peut-être des
mesures et surtout que vous nous disiez
ce que vous allez faire pour donner des
consignes au président d'université pour
éviter que ça se
reproduise JAC
groupin merci président merci Madame la
Ministre alors il y a les chiffres de la
police il y a les chiffres des
manifestants puis a les chiffres de
notre rapporteur sur les fond de
roulement des universités je voudrais
revenir dessus tout à l'heure parce que
c'est une réserve importante on l'a bien
compris parce qu'elle permettent à nos
universités de pourir engager des des
travaux de rénovation même si certaines
ne sont pas rentré dans ce système de
dévolution que moi j'appelais de mes
vœux depuis de nombreuses années parce
que je pense que c'est quelque chose qui
est important mais j'ai bien compris que
ce n'est pas dans la culture des
présidents diviversité vous avez dit
tout à l'heure que vous seriez vigilante
ou attentive aux situations
particulières donc c'est ma première
question que veut dire être vigilant
dans la mesure où on sait qu'il y a un
manque de compensation de l'État accordé
par l'État en tout cas au opérateur du
ha mesures salariales dans les factures
d'énergie estimées à 200 et 300 millions
d'euros par France université la deuxème
question ce sont les 500 millions
d'euros pour la rénovation du parc
immobilier universitaire monsieur gé
donc le président de France université
établissait la facture à 7 milliards
d'euros rappelons quand même l'excellent
rapport de de Stéphane piennoir sur le
fait que un tiers des du parc serait
qualifié de passoir énergétique on sait
que les prix d'énergie montent et cetera
et cetera est-ce que ça serait pas
intéressant de mettre en place alors que
notre Fran alors que la France oui notre
France d'ailleurs on peut le dire ce ve
acteur de la transition écog qu'est-ce
qu' ne serait pas intéressant de mettre
en place un réel plan ambitieux de
rénovation de notre parc universitaire
en tout cas immobilier en sachant tout
en prenant en compte bien sûr
l'autonomie des universités enfin une
dernière question sur
les les les propos que vous avez eu en
tout cas l'interview dont parlait tout à
l'heure Lord D'cos sur les appartements
du crus à hauteur de de donc de 200 €
qui serait réquisitionné est-ce que vous
avez budgetisé ça dans le PLF 2024 je
vous
remercie David cross David Ross
pardon merci monsieur le Président
Madame la Ministre alors je vais faire
un peu une intervention sur la recherche
un peu à l'image de la recherche c'estd
multiforme d'abord pour vous féliciter
pour votre volontarisme donc a un
affichage très clair d'une augmentation
des crédits dans la continuité de la LPR
même si il faudrait pondérer ça lié
d'une part à l'inflation et au coût
énergétique mais vous en nêtes pas
responsable mais effectivement regardez
aussi un petit peu en fonction des des
différents secteurs de la recherche
normalement l'augmentation des moyens
nourrit une ambition et devrait rassurer
or je rejoins mon collègue piennoir on
sent dans la communauté un certain
nombre d'inquiétudes donc je pense que
c'est important aussi de de les évoquer
le première il est lié au statut entre
le chercheur et l'enseignant chercheur
si j'ose dire un sujet qui revient
souvent mais qui là un petit peu
orchestré par l'attente du rapport gilet
et des mesures qui pourraient être
prises notamment sur le fléchage avec
les agences de moyens le deième ça a été
évoqué mais je tiens aussi à m'en faire
l'écho c'est les fonds de roulement et
donc là aussi puisque ces fonds de
roulement s'ils existent par qu'on peut
discuter de l'existance et du montant ce
sera un effort exceptionnel ponctuel qui
est là pour répondre à des questions
structurelles donc ça veut dire que il
faudrait qu'il des engagement pour qu'à
partir de l'année prochaine ces besoins
structurels soient assumés par l'État
ensuite il y a une inquiétude liée à
l'état des bâtiments et des coûts
énergétiques donc ça vient d'être dit à
l'instant et là aussi ces fonds
roulements auraient pu servir aurait dû
servir peut-être à accélérer la
transition des bâtiments universitaires
et de recherche et ça va m'amener à la à
ma première question qui est lié au post
il y a une augmentation d'un nombre de
postes que vous affichez qui sont ce
qu'on appelle des postes d'excellence
qui font aussi débat pour un certain
nombre d'enseignants chercheurs qui ont
affaire à des tâches au quotidien assez
harraçantes et se pose la question pour
moi des postes administratifs on a la
chance et j'en profite pour les saluer
d'avoir des administrateurs au Sénat de
très haut niveau l'université a un
certain nombre de personnes compétentes
à administration mais on manque de
compétences pour gérer les enjeux
auxquels l'université et les labos de
recherche sont confrontés et donc est-ce
qu'il faudrait pas cibler dans les
budgets des postes pour recruter à
niveau des gens au niveau de
l'administration qui accompagnent et y
compris pour faire la rénovation des
bâtiments énergétique parce que c'est
souvent très complexe et souvent s'il y
a des sous qui dorment c'est parce que
l'université est pas en capacité de les
dépenser à l'URE actuelle ensuite pour
terminer sur une ouverture de
perspective sur les défis que vous avez
un petit peu évoqué à la fois santé
médicale ça a été aussi dit avec le
biomédical mais climatique énergétique
et numérique est-ce qu'il y a des
dispositifs alors peut-être que là
encore les annonces autour du rapport
gilet nous donnerons des des
informations sur des priorités qui sont
faites de manière à ce qu'on soit
opérationnel et que on a des travaux à
la fois avec d'autres pays européens à
la fois avec les laboratoires les
organismes de recherches et les univers
unité mais aussi avec le lien entre la
recherche publique et la recherche
publique et privée pardon donc est-ce
qu'il y a des dispositifs en ce sens
dans le dans le casre de votre budget
enfin dernier point il me tient
particulièrement à cœur c'est celui de
l'attractivité notamment des jeunes donc
je sais pas si vous avez un retour sur
les incidences de la réforme du bac et
de parcours sub sur la poursuite des
études dans le supérieur moi j'ai
constaté sur un territoire que vous
connaissez que il y avait une baisse du
choix en math et en sciences des vie de
la terre donc je sais pas si ça se
traduit d'ors et déjà au niveau
universitaire alors qu'il y a des enjeux
importants sur le sujet et donc est-ce
que sur le domaine de du lien
interministériel avec l'Éducation
nationale est-ce qu'il y a un travail
particulier pour justement favoriser et
faire la valorisation de ces filières et
de pouvoir augmenter le nombre
d'ingénieurs de techniciens dont on aura
besoin pour l'avenir et pour pouvoir
répondre à tous ces sujet de société je
vous
remercie Catherine belrti
merci monsieur le Président Madame la
Ministre la vie étudiante engendre vous
le savez des coûts extrêmement
importantant pour pour les familles
aussi bien pour l'alimentation pour le
transport mais c'est surtout sur le
logement que je voudrais vous interroger
des avancées positives ont été déjà été
réalisé concernant l'alimentation avec
le repas à 1 € pour les élèves boursiers
mais la problématique principale de nos
étudiants aujourd'hui ben c'est celle du
logement depuis 2018 200000 étudiants de
plus sont arrivés sur le marché donc
pour 3 millions de jeunes au total face
à l'augmentation croissante du nombre
d'étudiants dans nos universités le
nombre de logement disponible dans le
parc locatif privé tant ind diminuer
ainsi en cette rentrée 2023-2024 il
manque 250000 logements environ et plus
grave encore les loyers demandés
explosent dans la crise actuelle que
connaît le logement en général dans
notre pays les cités universitaires les
résidences étudiantes privées manquent
elles aussi d'offre l'attribution de ces
chambres est soumise à des conditions de
ressources sauf qu'il y a 700 étudiants
boursiers en France pour 174000 places
disponibles dans les Cruises le CA est
donc clair le parc actuel de logement
étudiant est aujourd'hui largement
insuffisant si les dotations
d'investissement du réseau des œuvres
universitaires augmenteront de 25
millions d'euros dans le PLF soit une
hausse de 25 % pour poursuivre la
rénovation et la construction de
structures de rest et d'hébergement
l'objectif de 12000 rénovations d'ici la
fin du kakena reste bien insuffisant au
regard des besoins réels en logement et
de la situation catastrophique du marché
alors la question est simple quelle
mesures supplémentair le Gouvernement
entend-il prendre afin de permettre aux
étudiants et bien de de suivre une
scolarité dans des conditions de vie
décentes
merci Bernard
fialer merci monsieur le président
madame la prés madame la ministre une
question complémentaire sur finalement
l'égalité des chances la mixité sociale
des des étudiants on nous avait beaucoup
parlé du
tutor qui était assez étayant pour les
pour les étudiants qui qui fait
d'ailleurs parfois concurrence aux
officines qui elles sont assez
discriminantes donc tutudera et qui
permettait d'ailleurs qui permettrait
éventuellement à des étudiants aussi
d'avoir des ressources pour ceux qui
sont sont dans des situations difficiles
alors on a toujours salué cette
excellente idée mais qu'est-ce qu'il en
est pratiquement où on en est quelles
sont les lignes budgétaires pour y faire
face et est-ce qu'on a des chiffres
précis sur ce
tutor Mathilde Olivier
oui merci monsieur le président madame
la ministre je me joins aux
préoccupations de mes collègues sur la
précarité étudiante alors que 56 6 % des
étudiants rencontrent des difficultés
financières au point de réduire leur
alimentation 38 % peine à payer leur
loyer donc quelle est votre position au
sujet de cette allocation universelle
d'études que nous proposons et qui fait
notamment suite à l'appel de plusieurs
présidents d'université
euh ensuite une autre question
concernant l'attractivité de notre pays
vers les étudiantes et étudiants
étrangers j'ai entendu que c'était aussi
une de vos priorités euh les consulats
priorisent les les dossiers des
étudiants sur la période estivale pour
garantir un maximum d'étudiants d'arrivé
pour la rentrée universitaire en 2024
cette période de forte attractivité des
consulats sur les enfin de forte
activité pardon des consulats sur les
visas étudiants sera en même temps que
euh les JO qui généreront des fortes
demandes de visa aussi euh donc les
consulats sont déjà à flux tendu et ils
ne pourront pas faire à la fois les
demandes de visa pour les JO et puis les
visas étudiants est-ce que vous avez
anti anticiper cela d'un point de vue
budgétaire et organisationnel en
collaboration avec le ministère des
Affaires étrangères
euh et puis un dernier point sur la
rénovation des bâtiments universitaires
l'hiver approchant pourriez-vous nous
faire un point sur l'état des bâtiments
de nos universités et les objectifs de
rénovation euh thermique les collègues
en ont déjà parlé plus d'un tiers du
parc est dans un état pas ou peu
satisfaisant et donc les universit font
face à un défi de taille celui de la
rénovation donc les besoins sont
immenses estimés à 7 milliards d'euros
par le ministère 15 milliards par France
université alors où en êtes-vous sur les
objectifs de rénovation d'ici la fin du
quinquena Sonia de la provoté
oui merci monsieur le Président Madame
la Ministre de sujets le le premier
concerne les les les agences de de
programme et le choix qui va être
fait en définitif sur les les
thématiques qui vont être abordées et
l'articulation de ces agences qui sont
quand même toute un élément un AX
important de de la programmation de la
recherche avec la programmation France
2030 et sur la partie santé tout
particulièrement avec l'agence
d'innovation en santé parce que en
réalité en matière d'innovation et de
recherche puisque les deux sont liés on
voit bien qui les interlocuteurs sont de
plus en plus nombreux extra ministériel
euh et pour le coup peut-être serait-il
utile de dégager des orientations
communes une stratégie commune et donner
le sentiment que chacun participe à un
tout commun et non à son aspect
sectoriel euh donc c'est vraiment la la
la question de de de de la façon dont
les budgets recherches sont gérés et
s'articulent et ma deuxième question va
porter sur les masters alors c'est un
peu une question récurrente de rentrée
euh
universitaire on doit être normalement
au stade d'avoir le bilan de de de de la
rentrée master de de et de mon Master
voilà euh pour savoir où on en est on
sait qu'un certain nombre d'étudiants
n'avaient pas eu de réponse ou une
réponse qui collit vraiment pas du tout
avec leurs attentes parce qu'il y a des
décalages quand même assez assez
important ça c'est mon premier sujet
donc est-ce qu'on sait à peu près quels
sont les besoins et a-t-on toujours des
secteurs en tenstion comme la filière
droit par exemple qui avait été
identifié qui manifestement reste encore
une filière en tension et il avait été
évoqué quand même de travailler aussi le
contenu des licences en amont notamment
pour le droit également puisque la
licence telle qu'elle était conçue ne
permettait pas forcément d'accéder au
marché du travail si on avait pas de
Master je vous
remercie Karine
daniel Merci monsieur le Président
Madame la ministre mes chers collègues
tout d'abord moi je voudrais euh
renforcer et et et insister sur les
enjeux de précarité étudiante avec
peut-être un point spécifique sur l'état
des services de santé dans les
universités avec des plaquettes qui
donnent à la rentrée des perspectives de
de consultation et d'aide aux étudiants
qui sont parfois déçus par des délais
d'attente qui sont supérieurs à l'année
universitaire parfois donc donc on a un
vrai sujet sur la question de précarité
et de santé étudiante sur les enjeux
budgétaires ça a été dit euh là c'est
vraiment le le gros point
d'alerte on a une situation des des
établissements qui a été fortement
dégradé ces dernières années sous le
double effet de de l'inflation des
fluides mais aussi sur les enjeux de
revalorisation RH qui sont une bonne
nouvelle pour les personnels il faut
toujours le dire mais qui mettent les
établissements et les universités dans
une situation compliquée en terme de
compensation et et les annonces qui ont
été faites ne rassurent pas totalement
les présidentes et présidents
d'université dans ce dans ce domaine
puisque les
compensations n'apparaissent pas
évidemment n'apparaissent pas être total
et apparaissent flou sur certains
aspects donc on a là-dedans le le point
d'indice
revalorisé les primes exceptionnelles de
de pouvoir d'achat ou encore le
relèvement des indices pour les les
catégories B alors cette situation est
évidemment alarmante et compliquée à à
gérer alors il y a eu des des situations
budgétaire qui d'universités qui ont été
cité pour ce qui est par exemple de
l'Université de Nantes euh cette
université a a voter un un budget en
déficit pour 2023 de 11 millions d'euros
alors qu'elle est dans une situation où
ces fonds de de roulement auquel il est
fait appel sont sont parmi les plus
faibles et ne permettent pas de se
placer dans une perspective et dans une
dynamique positive on a là des équipes
qui sont à gérer des des déficits budget
à gérer des urgences à faire des
choix difficiles alors que l'université
devrait apparaître comme une forte
ressource aujourd'hui devant les défis
qui nous apparaissent devant nous on
parle souvent ici du manque de nombre de
médecin donc il y a une forte attente
après la la fin du numérus clausus pour
que les universités puisse répondre à
cette demande impérieuse de de de
nouveaux médecins euh à à mettre en
exercice dans dans les années qui
viennent mais on pourrait citer les
personnes qui demain géreront les
services publics de de proximité qui
préparent des concours à l'université on
pourrait citer tous les enjeux
évidemment climatiques énergétiques qui
sont aussi des sujets que nos
professeurs et les enseignants
chercheurs ont à cœur de de de relever
ce sont les défis qui sont devant nous
et et voilà c'est ces sujets doivent
être nos préoccupations et nos priorit
dernière intervenante Alexandra Borch
fontin merci monsieur le Président
Madame la
Ministre les Français évidemment ne
peuvent être que fiers de leur
chercheurs tant nos talons sont reconnus
au plus haut niveau comme on témoine
d'ailleurs l'obtention récente du prix
Nobel de physique chimie par Pierre
Agostini et Anne Lullier toutefois après
avoir regardé leur parcours et pris
connaissance évidemment aussi des
conditions dans lesquelles leurs
recherches ont été menées il s'est avéré
que comme de plus en plus de
scientifiques la France ne leur aurait
pas permis en tout cas d'atteindre un
tel niveau alors ma question est simple
et c'est la suivante avez-vous des des
pistes de de travail d'alemement même
des mesures pour que nos chercheurs
nationaux puissent donc continuer à
effectuer leur travail leurs travaux
pardon dans leur
pays voilà madame la ministre de
nombreuses questions certaines
évidemment se se recoupe je vais essayer
de grouper le plus possible merci
monsieur le Président je je vais
peut-être commencer par la la fin madame
la sénatrice ça me donne l'occasion
effectivement on est fier de nos prix
Nobel et il faut se réjouir quand on a
des bonnes nouvelles de ce type sont
rares et je voudrais tout de suite vous
rassurer les deux prix Nobel que nous
venons d'avoir comme celui de l'année
dernière à la aspect en physique qui a
fait toute sa carrière en France et qui
encore pour l'un a fait toute sa
carrière en France le prix Nobel ils
l'ont eu ensemble en France sur une
manib du CEA pour Anne elle était en
France elle a commencé sa carrière en
France sur un poste du CEA comme a fait
toute sa carrière l'autre chercheur
aussi et elle est partie pour des
raisons personnelles
oserais-je dire par amour voilà ce que
d' une bonne raison mais je j'ose euh en
Suède et donc je pense que cela fait
partie effectivement bah de de mobilité
de la vie mais mais qu'en tout cas leur
prix Nobel ils l'ont obtenu sur une
manipe qui est en France au CEA et des
travaux qu'ils ont menés et pour une
part qui a fait toute sa carrière en
France jusqu'à la retraite donc voilà je
c'est je pense que il y a des gens des
prix Nobel ou des médaille fils qui
partent qui viennent je pense que le ça
n'empêche pas que le problème
d'attractivité on en a parlé tout à
l'heure reste quelque chose qui doit
nous être dans notre attention
particulière et je vous rejoins sur ce
point nous devons donner envie à nos
jeunes nous devons attirer donner de
bonnes conditions à tous nos chercheurs
parce qu'on ne fera pas de la recherche
qu'avec les prix Nobel mais nous devons
être fiers quand il y a nos prix Nobel
aussi donc c'est cet équilibre et cette
diversité de la recherche que l'on doit
continuer à à alimenter aussi bien dans
nos priorités que notre attractivité
mais là nous pouvons entièrement être fi
de nos derniers prix Nobel de physique
cette année et l'année dernière par
rapport aux travaux réalisés en France
voilà mais je vous rejoins sur ce souci
d'attrac activité sur euh peut-être en
en
remontant madame Danielle euh madame la
sénatrice donc je je vais peut-être en
profiter pour faire sur la précarité
étudiante donc vous avez parlé de la
santé en particulier exactement en
particulier santé mentale psychologue
donc c'est un point évidemment qui est
en exerg depuis le covid qui se met de
plus en plus nos jeunes ont payé un
lourd tribut par rapport au covid et
après et c'est pour pour ça que d'une
part l'année dernière et nous allons
avoir un bilan en décembre je pourrais
vous le présenter plutôt en 2024 sur
l'évolution des services de santé
universitaire en service de santé
étudiant un des points c'est vous avez
parlé des délais c'est de réduire les
délais de visite en particulier pour les
étudiants en situation de handicap ou
les étudiants qui sont en malêtre pour
qu'ils puissent avoir leur visite et du
coup comme pour tous les étudiants de
enfin les jeunes de moins de 25 ans il y
a ces visites de façon générale nous a
avons pu enlever l'obligation de visite
à tous les étudiants en entrée et c'est
plutôt des étudiants en situation
particulière qui seront prioritaire pour
pour pour accélérer les la cadence des
visites donc c'est aussi donné accès à
tous les étudiants d'un territoire donc
un service de santé étudiant mutualisé
pour cela j'ai rajouté plus 8 millions
d'euros en 2023 en particulier pour
renforcer les forces chez les médecins
et les salaires de médecins et
d'infirmièrees et nous avons mis 80
postes de de de psychologues euh
pérennes au niveau 2023 dans ses
services et dans les établissement 80
postes titulaires euh de psychologues
dans les services et puis nous avons
demandé aussi à un projet de recherche
euh propsi euh qui est mené c'est un P
sur la santé mentale d'avoir un acte sur
la santé des jeunes et en particulier
santé étudiants et de travailler avec
les centres experts qui maillent notre
territoire pour pouvoir avoir des relais
avec effectivement nos services de de
santé étudiant donc nous aurons un bilan
fin d'année ou début d'année prochaine
sur les services de santé étudiants avec
une focale un focus particulier sur la
santé mentale sur je je vais peut-être
faire un groupement sur la précarité
étudiant me permettre puisque plusieurs
questions sur les bourses ou le modèle
des bourses vous m'avez interpellé sur
en gros deux types de modèles monsieur
le sénateur madame la sénatrice
plusieurs d'entre vous donc sur un
modèle d'allocation universelle je vais
le faire simple et sur le modèle de
bourse évidemment remis à plat mais sur
critères sociaux pour voilà même si sur
les deux nous souhaitons avoir une
évolution par rapport au profil
d'étudiants et à la précarité dans les
deux cas peut-être trois points premier
point je je vous rejoins et c'est pour
ça que nous nous sommes battus et que le
gouvernement a mis c un demimilliard et
sur cette première étape sur l'urgence
de la précarité et je pense que il est
urgent de trouver des solutions à la
précarité et que si l'on parle
d'autonomie c'est pas obligatoirement
les mêmes mesures et le même discours
sur la précarité étudiant et sur une
plus grande
autonomie pour les étudiants
premièrement deuxièmement sur la partie
àocation qui rejoint les deux allocation
universelle et critère de bourse vous
avez dit pour rejoindre sur quelques
pays le font en fait le Danemark pas
quelques pays et le Danemark on peut pas
je le dis toujours piocher des points de
modèle différents un modèle c'est un
modèle global aussi bien un modèle
social qu'un modèle économique le
Danemark c'est beaucoup moins
d'étudiants c'est un système plus
sélectif à l'entrée dans l'enseignement
supérieur ce n'est pas un modèle
d'allocation universel à tous les
étudiants c'est pour les
décabitants les gens les étudiants qui
restent chez leurs parents ils ont
souvent moins que les bourses que l'on
permet en France et donc c'est un vrai
problème enfin un vrai problème en tout
cas c'est un autre modèle social et
c'est pas pour tous les étudiants et
c'est un autre modèle d'accès à
l'enseignement supérieur et c'est un
autre je dirais euh philosophie de
modèle deuxème chose je pense que ce
modèle d'allocation universelle pour moi
et et je veux vous dire clairement que
je suis pour le modèle à critères
sociaux et pas d'allocation universelle
ce qui n'empêche pas que je l'ai étudié
que je suis d'accord pour regarder toute
façon je suis toujours d'accord pour
regarder des choses pour les étudiants
et donc il ne faut se priver d'étudier
aucun modèle sur le fond comme sur le
financement et c'est pour ça que je ne
voudrais pas mélanger le problème de
philosophie de politique apportée sur ce
modèle et le problème de financement
dont je parlerai dans un deuxième temps
pour moi c'est d'abord un problème de
nous sommes des étudiants c'est-à-dire
des adultes et nous avons aussi la
responsabilité de leur inculquer un
modèle social basé sur une solidarité et
le fait d'aider de combattre la la
précarité étudiante c'est d'aider mieux
et plus ce ceux qui en ont le plus
besoin et je crois que ça et en tout cas
ça sera ma priorité et plus et mieux
ceux qui en a le plus besoin je ne pense
pas qu'avoir un modèle d'allocation
universelle c'est-à-dire de donner à
tous quels que soient les revenus de
l'étudiant ou de la famille permettent
de mieux combattre la précarité et je
pense que même ça va à l'encontre de la
philosophie même d'un modèle d'alloc
enfin d'un modèle social basé sur la
solidarité et oui pour aider plus oui
pour aider mieux pour aider tout le
monde quel qu que soit la situation non
et je pense pas que ça soit non plus
quelque chose que l'on peut porter
vis-à-vis d'adultes d'adultes qui sont
dans une situation effectivement d'étude
que l'on doit leur permettre de
favoriser mais sur lequel aujourd'hui
comme réponse nous avons un modèle qui
comprend le cru avec de la restauration
et je crois qu'on a le seul pays où il y
a plusieurs réponses on ne doit pas
regarder que les bourses ou que la
restauration ou que le logement c'est un
ensemble d'aide qui permet d'aider
différemment les profils différents
d'étudiants et c'est pour ça que quand
j'ai fait les concertations
territoriales et nationales je n'ai pas
voulu discuter que des bourses ou que du
logement mais de mettre tout le monde
autour de la table au national comme au
local pour discuter de l'ensemble des
problématiques de vie étudiante et des
aides apportées sur les étudiants au
niveau j'y reviendrai logement
restauration et les bourses et si je
reviens sur le dernier point du modèle
financier que j'ai regardé que nous
avons quand même regardé si je vous fais
un calcul très rapide de nous avons 3
million à peu près d'étudiants en France
je ne prends que 2004 si j'enlève les
apprentis mais même avec 2004 1000 € par
mois je vous le fais à la louche mais
vous allez voir ça suffit 1000 € par
mois sur 10 mois c'est-à-dire 10000 €
par an pour chaque étudiant vous il vous
faut un budget de 24 milliards d'euros
24 milliards d'euros à à quelque chose
près c'est le budget de mon ministère en
entier aujourd'hui le budget de la vie
étudiante c'est plutôt 10 fois moins
c'est environ 3 milliards d'euros et
donc si je revois le modèle entièrement
et que je dis ce qui est un peu le
modèle pas complètement mais d'ois je
prends la demi-part fiscale j'enlève le
cru je réinjecte tous les 3 milliards si
vous avez un enfant 10000 € par an je ne
pense pas que la 2000 par fiscale on est
loin d'avoir un abattement de 10000 €
par an par rapport au revenus universel
donc pour rentrer dans un modèle
économique il faudrait peut-être et prêt
à continuer à en discuter avec vous à
regarder mais non seulement enlever
complètement les avantages du cru qui
peut apporter différemment différentes
solutions à différents profils
d'étudiants mais aussi les APL mais
aussi la demi-part fiscale et je pense
que l'on peut plus aider avec
différentes formes d'aide d'allocation
sociale en fonction de des besoins
plutôt que d'avoir une règle unique qui
coûte euh très cher mais encore une fois
je préfère mettre le coût euh en 2e rang
par rapport à une question de politique
portée de fil rouge de philosophie que
je souhaite porter aussi vis-à-vis
d'étudiants adulte donc voilà pour euh
merci j'ai j'ai pris un peu de temps
mais je pense que c'est une question
importante et bien sûr à disposition
pour continuer à l'étudier euh
évidemment j'en discute avec les 14
présidents je vous enfin voilà je je
vous encite fortement à discuter avec
certains de ces 14 présidents pour
savoir comment ils voyaient les choses à
travers de leur tribune je pense que ce
n'est pas une simple allocation
universelle que certains voyaient à
travers mais surtout une alerte et une
prise en compte des besoins des
étudiants et en ça on le partage
fortement je voulais revenir aussi
madame la sénatrice et plus globalement
alors pour aussi le problème des bourses
puisque je finirai avec celui-là vous
m'avez monsieur le sénateur demandé le
bilan je crois un peu de cette première
étape effectivement avec les données de
l'année dernière nous avons simulé
modélisé 35000 étudiants boursiers en
plus et 140000 qui bougent et
aujourd'hui en tout cas je n'ai pas de
bilan final mais nous pourrons vous le
transmettre mais le premier bilan je
crois que c'était fin août des premières
bourses fixées c'était 78 si je dis pas
de bêtises 1000 16 76000 étudiants
supplémentaires c'est-à-dire à fin août
à chiffre équivalent à l'année dernière
c'estàd 20 % de plus mais je reste
prudente ça ne veut pas dire que au
final on aura ces 76000 étudiants de
plus puisque là je vous donne la
comparaison chiffre à chiffre de ce qu'
avait l'année dernière fin août par
rapport à fin août de cette année donc
on est sur une pente très positif et
effectivement d'une augmentation du
nombre de boursiers même plus qu'attendu
pour l'instant mais en restant prudent
sur les problèmes RH mais plus
globalement de financement et de fond de
roulement d'énergie et cetera euh je
suis bien évidemment consciente des
difficultés budgétaires de nos
établissements je voudrais peut-être en
complément de ce que j'ai dit dans
présentation faire plusieurs commentaire
le premier c'est que ce soit 1 milliard
ou 600 millions je prends même pas le
euh d'abord vous dire ce 1 milliard ou
600 millions d'euros et France
université l'a dit aussi il parle bien
de fond de roulement disponible ça veut
dire quoi et bien sûr euh je d'abord
même si c'est 1 milliard quand vous
divisez par 130 établissements parce que
c'est à peu près l'ordre de grandeur
vous voyez qu'on relativise le nombre de
fond le le le la le le les fonds de
roulements disponibles par établissement
quand vous savez les problématiques
d'inflation ou de projets infrastructure
les dépassements qu' peut y avoir on
sait que il est de bonne gestion de
pouvoir garder du fond de roulement et
c'est l'autonomie des universités leur
responsab AB ilité la gestion d'angard
donc ce n'est pas un problème
effectivement ni de mauvaise gestion ni
d'amasser une richesse au cours des
années parce que sur un certain je
dirais niveau il y a des besoins mais ce
que l'on voit c'est qu'il y a à peu près
chaque année depuis plusieurs années
chaque année au moment des comptes une
augmentation d'environ 300 millions
d'euros des comptes au total de fonds de
roulement ce qui fait que quand on
regarde l'évolution des fonds de
roulement de nos établissements il il
monte de façon régulière depuis des
années chaque année et environ entre 300
et 500 millions d'euros par an au moment
du compte en mars et donc c'est vrai
qu'au début d'année on a toujours des
difficultés à boucler les budgets et en
fin d'année nous avons des fonds de
roulement et donc quand on a fait une
enquête cette année ce qu'on appelle des
fonds de roulement disponibles on a
enlevé tout ce qui était voté par les ca
que ce soit les projets fléchés des CP
des contrats et ce et cetera de la
trésorerie que ce soit les 15 jours de
précaution que ce soit les projets votés
en
CA à tout prix et quand on a enlevé tout
ça c'est ce qui n'est pas voté en CA
pour une utilisation dans les années à
venir qui représente entre les 600
millions d'euros et 1 milliard d'euros
et donc évidemment que l'idée est de
faire un projet typiquement de
rénovation thermique nous y travaillons
avec les établissements avec des modèles
de tiers financement par exemple un
groupe de travail avec aussi la dieie
est en cours pour voir comment on
s'atelle à faire cette rénovation
évidemment les fonds de roulement
peuvent y être injectés mais l'état des
lieux qui était d'ailleurs le même d'il
y a un an quand je me suis présenté
devant vous est toujours le même et donc
il faut aider aussi et c'est pour ça que
j'ai proposé aux universités de
travailler le modèle économique le
modèle économique étant aussi la façon
de dépenser l'argent de prévoir sur le
long terme de gérer parce que ils ont
aussi des freins à l'utilisation de
gestion de leur argent en particulier
des fonds de roulement donc c'est pas
facile c'est pas noir c'est pas blanc
c'est pas un problème de mauvaise
gestion mais c'est un problème qu'on est
actuellement en difficulté budgétaire
qu'on a un problème de dette qu'on a cet
argent exceptionnellement disponible et
clairement ça ne peut être que les
l'utilisation de fonds de roulement sur
une année et que clairement pour les
autres années ces fonds de roulement ne
peuvent pas continuer à compenser la
masse sal
alors pourquoi par rapport aux postes
par rapport aux campagnes emploi ils
n'ont pas été utilisés parce que vous le
savez les fonds de roulement ne peuvent
pas être utilisés pour de la masse
salariale sauf dérogation que l'on a
demandé de donner au recteur pour
l'utilisation exceptionnelle et ne
peuvent être utilisés que pour de
l'investissement ce qui fait que voilà
c'est pas parce que il y a du fond de
roulement qu'ils peuvent investir dans
de la masse salarial et pour compenser
pour les postes exemple de Créteil et
comme je l'ai dit nous identifions les
établissements parce que c'est très
hétérogène qui ont des problématiques
financières particulières et j'ai
annoncé si vous lisez mon interview du
Parisien il y a quelques peu de temps et
je viendrai comme ça au logement j'ai
annoncé pour créteille une aide
exceptionnel de 3 millions d'euros sur
la fin de gestion pour pouvoir les aider
et revoir aussi parce que je sais au
combien les campagnes emploi sont
précieus plus une aide aussi par rapport
à leur problèm de de de bâtiment
d'immobilier euh qu'ils ont à à
créteille de 7 millions d'euros pour
l'étude bâtimentaire parce que ça aussi
ça leur crée un un problématique
d'investissement donc nous allons
accompagner dès cette année et dès la
fin de gestion l'université de créteille
avec une enveloppe non négligeable dans
cette enveloppe non négligeable par
exemple des 3 millions d'euros 1 million
d'euros est lié à les au surcût
énergétique et donc ça me permet de
revenir sur ce point du surcou
énernergétique puisque nous avions
débloqué l'année dernière 275 millions
d'euros rappelez sur les problèmes de
surcût il nous en reste 100 pour les
établissements d'enseignement supérieur
et de recherche nous avions dit que nous
les débloquerons sur des coût réels et
nous sommes en train de de de distribuer
ces 100 millions d'euros en fin de
gestion sur les établissements par
rapport au coût réel de surcût d'énergie
donc l'État a été là avec ses 275
millions d'euros pour accompagner les
surcûts énergétiques surcûts qui avait
été évalué en début d'année à 400
millions d'euros pour l'année 2023 au
jour d'aujourd'hui encore une fois je
suis prudente nous sommes plutôt aux
alentours de 200 millions d'euros de
surcût énergétique pour 2023 que 400 et
donc on voit que ces 275 millions
d'euros vont pouvoir permettre de de de
d'aider et de compenser les
établissements sur les frais réels de
surcût énergétique pour 2023 pour 2024
nous avons dit aux établissements
d'abord ça doit baisser les évaluations
baissent énormément et nous serons là
pour accompagner et suivre les surcûts
aussi énergétiques sur 2024 il ne nous
semble pas dans les difficultés actuel
d'anticiper et nous les accompagnerons
comme nous l'avons fait cette année sur
les surcouts énergétiques donc je je je
vraiment nous sommes vigilant à ne pas
impacter les projets des établissements
à ne pas impacter les campagnes emploi
des établissements avec cette
compensation exceptionnelle en 2024
demander et cette autorisation
exceptionnelle à prendre sur les fonds
de roulement pour la masse salariale et
de regarder comment ils accompagnés à
long terme à partir de 2025 voilà je
voulais vraiment revenir
dessus madame la la sénatrice je voulais
revenir sur les biosanté plus
globalement certains d'entre vous et
revenir aussi sur le volet
interministériel de de de à la fois
madame la sénatrice Lord Arcos sur le
budget recherche aussi oui la mission
Manuel Tunon de Lara et Anne-Marie
armmentterrasse ont un volet sur le
budget recherche c'est une mission
commune cignée par le ministère de la
santé et le ministère de l'enseignement
supérieur la recherche sur comme je l'ai
dit tout à l'heure beaucoup de volets
mais dont un ça doit être de
l'interministériel le but de ces agences
de programme c'est de mettre tous les
acteurs autour de la table que ce soit
les acteurs de la recherche que les
ministère donc au niveau
interministériel et de revoir de
regarder comment on on finance le budget
recherche sur des enveloppes qui qui
existent aujourd'hui qui sont utilisées
aussi bien par exemple sur le biosanté
ministère de la Santé et ministère de la
recherche donc nous y travaillons
ensemble et c'est un des objectifs de la
mission du N de la rare terrasse qui va
rendre ses ses conclusions probablement
d'ici la fin de l'année
euh ça j'ai fait alors sur les les
logements peut-être et les Jeux
Olympiques mais plus globalement les
logements vous avez été plusieurs à à
alors déjà sur les Jeux Olympiques et le
logement je voudrais merci beaucoup de
la question ça me permet d'expliquer
donc c'est un travail que l'on fait vous
je ne vais pas répéter que l'on
accueille un événement planétaire
l'année prochaine sur cet événement
planétaire dans l'île-de-fance
uniquement dans l'île-de-fance il y a
des besoins pour loger nos agents
publics qui viendront renforcés ça peut
être des agents médecins infirmières de
soins des pompiers des agents de force
de l'ORD des agents de sécurité agent
public et donc chaque année en
Île-de-France nous avons 6000 logements
cru vided don le le bail se termine fin
juin chaque année et donc nous avons
répondu avec la proposition de mettre
3000 de ces logements ça sera 3200
exactement pour effectivement loger les
agents publics qui viendront pendant les
Jeux olympiques d'été renforcer sur
l'île-de-fance les les les les services
publics pour assurer de de beaux jeux
olympiques donc il n'est pas question
évidemment de mettre nos étudiants à la
porte bien évidemment ça se prépare
depuis l'année dernière des à pe il y a
12 résidences qui représentent ces 3000
logements qui ont été identifiés
identifiés sur le site pour que les
étudiants sachent que s'ils vont sur ces
résidences et qu'ils les choisissent
parce qu'ils mettent des listes on leur
demandera et on leur proposera des
logements en proximité de déménager
pendant juillet et août évidemment leur
proposant un logement équivalent sans
surcout à proximité nous sommes en train
de mener une enquête auprès de ses
étudiants pour savoir à quelle période
ça leur dérangera le moins de déménager
et on déménage une chambre étudiante et
on compensera le défrément de ces
déménagement avec 100 € pour permettre
le déménagement et comme ils seront là
pendant les vacances d'été on a proposer
de leur donner de leur faire profiter de
deux places pour les Jeux Olympiques ces
100 € permettent le défraéement du
déménagement du déménagement dans une
chambre équivalente sans surcût et que
l'on accompagne et donc ce travail on va
le faire à partir de maintenant à partir
d'une enquête fait à partir de ces
étudiants mais qui savent qu'ils sont
dans ses résidences pourquoi on les
bouge parce que vous le savez il y a des
pompiers des agents de forces de l'ordre
et des agents médicaux leur horaire ne
correspond pas à le horaire de vie
étudiante qui s'il y a des étudiants qui
restent l'été c'est par exemple pour
réviser il y a des concours de médecine
maintenant qui sont en octobre les ECN
ont changé en octobre les étudiants
révisent tard pour des secondes sessions
ou tôt pour des concours et donc il nous
a semblé que la vie étudiante et la vie
des agents de de service public pendant
les Jeux Olympiques n'étit pas
compatible et donc pour le bien-être de
chacun on a préféré regrouper dans des
résidences universitaires voilà donc et
et simplement pour dire dans les
problématiques de logement nous avons un
héritage des Jeux Olympiques puisque
nous allons récupérer dès la rentrée
prochaine 1600 logements à partir de
nouveaux bâtiments des Jeux Olympiques
1300 en Île-de-France dans le village
olympique et 300 à Lille pour permettre
d'augmenter très rapidement le nombre de
logements étudiants en héritage des Jeux
Olympiques parce que nous avons besoin
de logement étudiant d'urgence alors sur
les logements peut-être trois volets
premièrement la rénovation pour avoir
des des des états de nos résidences
universitaires en bon état nous avons
lancé et financer dans les 25 millions
d'euros supplémentaires en 2024 un plan
de rénovation des 7 % de logements
résidence étudiantes ça correspond à
12000 logements étudiants qu'il reste à
rénover le plan est finalisé les 300
millions d'euros jusqu'en 2027 sont là
nous avons mis 25 millions
supplémentaires l'année prochaine et le
rousse à son plan de financement pour la
rénovation pour finir la rénovation des
12000 logements étudiants ensuite il y a
aussi la construction de nouveaux
logements étudiants avec le ministre
vergrit nous finalisons un plan pour les
30000 supplémentaires vous savez le plan
des 600000 logements il en manque
environ 30000 le problème est un
problème de foncier comme pour beaucoup
de problèmes logement donc nous avons
une mission de Richard lioget qui est en
train d'identifier minutieusement les
fonciers un universitaire et de villes
disponibles nous avons déjà et je l'ai
annoncé identifié un foncier pour 10000
logements étudiants que nous allons
mettre en œuvre avec le cru ou avec des
bailleurs sociaux et nous allons
effectivement continuer à faire ce plan
de 30000 logements supplémentairire et
puis nous rénovons des par exemple des
des résidences en augmentant aussi en
surélevant les résidences comme celles
de Bordeau que j'ai inauguré récemment
ou d'autres pour essayer d'avoir des
logements supplémentaires rapidement par
parce que les constructions prennent du
temps donc nous essayons de finaliser un
plan de logement pour les étudiants pour
l'année prochaine en augmentant le parc
en voyant aussi comment faire de
l'intergénérationnel ou autre et avec un
plan de construction de nouveaux
logements par le cru et par des
bailleurs sociaux donc c'est en cours
avec le ministre du Logement donc voilà
sur le logement
euh peut-être monsieur le sénateur Ross
je quelques réponses complémentaires sur
la baisse enfin la baisse d'attractivité
pour nos étudiants particulier math SVT
ou autres oui nous travaillons avec le
ministre de l'éducation national Gabriel
Atal je vais pas être synthétique mais
sur les professeurs des écoles je pense
que c'est un point clé sur la formation
des professeurs des écoles avec des
socles en sciences beaucoup plus larges
et beaucoup plus solides sur une
formation des écoles en premier cycle
sur l'orientation beaucoup plus tôt et
donc nous allons utiliser les données de
parcours sup pour lancer aussi une
plateforme à partir de la seconde pour
mieux choisir les épreuves de les
spécialités les options de spécialité et
puis nous avons un financement avec
France 2030 dans compéten et métiers
d'avenir pour ouvrir des formations
typiquement ingénieur ou des formations
là où il y a des métiers en tension ou
dans d'autres disciplines et nous
accompagnons actuellement les
établissements à ouvrir des formations
sciences mais effectivement il faut y
travailler en amont sur l'orientation et
sur l'attractivité euh des des études
scientifiques donc c'est un un travail
qui est mené sur les postes
administratifs oui j'en suis totalement
consciente c'est un travail que nous
menons dans le cadre des contrats
d'objectifs de moyens et de performance
en faisant avec certains établissements
des expérimentation de de visibilité
ressources humaines de
repyramidage vous avez dans France 2030
l'appel à projet d'asdsr ce sont comment
on va accompagner les chercheurs par
exemple dans les directions de projets
européen direction de développement
économique de formation continue avec
des posts de haut niveau et puis comment
repyramider faire du repyramidage de
postes pour monter en compétence les
postes administratifs et techniques dans
nos établissements je pense que c'est
quelque chose que nous pourrons
rediscuter lorsque je viendrai vous
présenter le bilan LPR parce que ça doit
peut-être faire partie de de points que
nous pourrons travailler dans la suite
euh sur les statuts chercheurs
enseignant chercheurs et les les le
point gilet nous y reviendrons mais nous
te touchons pas au statut je l'ai dit je
le redit chercheurs enseignant chercheur
même si nous souhaitons avoir des
incitations fortes à ce que les
chercheurs fassent de l'enseignement à
les englober dans la vie de nos
établissements d'enseignement supérieur
de recherche ce qui est déjà le cas mais
de de continuer à augmenter ce ce
travail en commun mais il n'y a pas de
modification de statut qui sont prévu ni
via la les agences de programme ni via
d'autres
évolutions euh juste peut-être pour
remercier même si monsieur le sénateur
Lévy mais je voulais revenir les 25
millions sont bien en plus pas à la
place de quoi que ce soit pour l'année
2024 et nous allons travailler
effectivement dans la mise en œuvre par
rapport à à cette mise en œuvre qui est
de calendrier donc avec d'abord mais
vous le savez une restauration
collective et augmenter les les
conventions avec enfin hôpitaux privés
lycées pour donner accès à une
restauration collective sur les campus
c'est ce qui est en cours et que nous
mettrons en œuvre le plus rapidement
possible dans ce cadre là et puis
effectivement ce carte de paiement
prépayé pour des étudiants le dernier
kilomètre à faire qui n'auront pas accès
à ces restaurations et nous sommes en
train d'avoir une solution à recharger
mensuellement de cartes prépayées h pour
un nombre non négligeable d'étudiants et
je pense que l'année 2024 va nous
permettre d'évaluer ces coûts et ce
nombre d'étudiants par convention
collective et par ces cartes prépayées
que nous mettrons en œuvre courant 2024
et nous aurons une perspective meilleure
pour défendre le budget 2025 donc voilà
pour répondre je garde les problèmes
d'antisémitisme pour la fin je ne les
oublie pas tellement ils sont importants
je voudrais monsieur Brisson est parti
mais répondre à un point qui est
fondamental et je pense que nous
pourrons en reparler lors du bilan LPR
c'est la part de dépenses des 2,2 % de
PIB qui ne bougeent pas comment
l'expliquer euh je je vous propose je
vous en dis un mot mais c'est
typiquement le point à discuter lorsque
je reviendrai vous présenter le bilan
LPR les perspectives d'évolution je
pense qu'il faut regarder dans les
rapports de l'OCDE la dépense ce qui est
efficace parce que c'est réellement ce
qu'on dépense pour la recherche donc
c'est important d'avoir ce 3 % mais mais
aussi ce qu'on injecte et vous le savez
dans cette dépense de 2,2 % il y a la
part publique et il y a la part privée
et aussi dans l'investissement si vous
regardez les rapports de l'OCDE vous
voyez que la France est 8e ou en tout
cas a perdu sur les dépenses recherche
publique et privé par contre au niveau
de l'investissement public on est à 1 %
du PIB c'estàdire ce qu'on injecte en
public et là on est très bien positionné
par rapport au pays du G7 voire par
rapport à l'Union européenne ça veut
dire qu'il faut regarder et étudier ce
qu'il manque comme financement entre la
part publique la part privée aussi bien
pour la recherche comment les obtenir
tout en ayant en tête qu'évidemment
cette part aussi bien en investissement
qu'en dépense est très intrinsquement
lié au modèle que nous défendons pour
l'enseignement supérieur et la recherche
mais c'est un enfin c'est une vraie
question et mon explication de ce qu'on
m'a demandé c'est aussi à regarder part
privé part publique et utilisation de la
part privée investissement et dépenses
et donc nous ferons un un bilan et je
reviendrai vers vous pour faire un bilan
sur cette analyse de 2,2 % versus les 3
% de PIB à atteindre
euh
peut-être un
point sur je crois que ça j'ai répondu
les CDI mission c'est en cours donc non
on ne lâche pas et donc j'ai fait un
petit bilan avec certaines universités
je reviens de Corse et par exemple le
président m'a dit qu'il commençait
fortement à les utiliser donc je pense
que la dynamique des cidé de mission qui
était un peu après la dynamique des CPJ
est en train de se mettre en route et
nous allons regarder comment elle se met
en route mais nous ne l'abandonnons pas
et elle a l'air d'être de plus en plus
utilisée par les établissements cette
année en tout cas
euh sur
alors je voudrais répondre globalement
sur la dégradation des universités et
surtout finir peut-être à moins que j'ai
oublié des points et n'hésitez pas mais
sur les problèmes et je les je les
peut-être présenterai sous la forme de
respect de nos valeur de la République
vous le savez je suis une fervante
défentrice des autonomies des
universités la liberté académique c'est
vrai et je suis universitaire et je sais
aussi le le bien fondé de ces libertés
académiques pour toute démocratie et
aussi la professionnalisation vis-à-vis
de l'autonomie des universités mais
alors là je vous rejoins entièrement et
c'est ce que j'ai fait depuis autant il
y a des points sur lequel je crois que
voilà on ne peut pas dépasser autant là
sur les valeurs de la République
l'université est garante de ces valeurs
de la République doit l'être et nous
devons avoir une tolérance zéro par
rapport évidemment au respect de la loi
c'est une évidence mais dans le cadre
républicain et c'est dans ce cadre-là
que j'ai écrit le 8 octobre au président
d'université euh pour rappeler
effectivement ce cadre pour donner aussi
euh un avis plus qu'un avis un un
témoignage sur ce qui s'est passé et une
position claire euh clairement
l'incitation à la haine à la violence
antisémitisme
ou autre type n'ont pas leur place à
l'université je l'ai toujours défendu
dans toute ma carrière et je le défend
encore plus fort au niveau des des en
tant que ministre j'ai donné des
consignes claires à tous les
établissements nous avons je dirais
construit un réseau entre recteur préfet
et président d'université depuis début
octobre qui n'a jamais eu lieu à ce
point pour effectivement réagir par
rapport à ce qui se passe réagir en
commission disciplinaire réagir aussi
sur les campus en effaçant les tags en
effaçant en certains en enlevant
certaines affiches euh en en en déposant
des articles 40 et ça se fait à peu près
dans la journée quand c'est pas dans les
2hes et je pense que toutes les campus
sont concerné et quand il y a des points
de crispation nous sommes en lien
directement avec les présidents
d'université pour évaluer le problème
parce que effectivement et avec les
préfectures parce que les problèmes je
reprends le l'exemple de Toulouse 2 pour
être très précise je voudrais signaler
que suite à la manifestation qui s'est
produise la présidente sur lequelle nous
avons travaillé a fait un article 40
donc un article 40 a été déposé par la
présidente euh et nous travaillons avec
la parce que pour pouvoir interdire mais
vous le savez c'est vrai aussi au niveau
préfecture en dehors des universités il
faut des alertes à trouble à l'ordre au
trouble à l'ordre public il faut
vraiment d'avoir des points parce que
c'est pire que tout lorsque l'ensuite
nos décisions sont je dirais
confronté au tribunal administrative et
que l'on perd et je pense que dans ce
cas-là on ne fait que renforcer
certaines actes qui sont juste enfin
avoir tolérance zéro donc nous les
accompagnons de plus fort je pense enfin
au plus près nous mettons en œuvre des
commissions disciplinaires nous vous
avez vu que certains présidents un des
présidents a suspendu un professeur à
fait un article 40 et vous avez vu que
récemment pour d'autres raisons j'ai
suspendu un président d'université avec
article 40 et commission disciplinaire
donc sur ces sujets-là je peux vous dire
que ma main ne tremblera pas
ne tremblera d'autant moins que c'est
une conviction qu'elle doit être un
toolérance zéro j'ai réuni les référents
antisémitisme je suis en lien avec
Samuel le joyeux avec l'Union des
étudiants juuses de France très proche
nous avons réuni ensemble les référents
antisémitisme discrimination et racisme
des universités nous sommes en train de
travailler à un renforcement avec la
Licra des formations euh nous avons mis
des financements pour renforcer les
formations et nous coordonnons ces
référents avec aussi les les les haut
fonctionnaires défense et sécurité ou
d'autres référents laïcité ou autres
donc nous essayons d'augmenter les
formations la prévention mais aussi
l'accompagnement aux victimes et aussi
ben les enfin les les les les actions
très fortes euh qui sont lorsque nous
avons nous suivons d'ACT je voudrais
quand même finir par un côté positif je
pense que nous pouvons regarder nos
universités par tout ce qui se passe
d'une part sans avoir enfin vraiment en
étant très vigilant et euh en suivant de
près et croyez-moi nous le faisons mais
aussi par rapport à d'autres pays en
regardant que nous ne nous avons des
universités qui ne monent pas dans des
actes antisémitisme forthureusement
autant et c'est pas pour autant qu'on
s'en contente mais nous avons des
exemples dans d'autres pays qui sont
catastrophiques donc pourquoi je crois
que ce réseau fonctionne nous avons un
discours clair et oui nous devons
continuer à l'avoir et si vous avez des
enfin des des des enfin des des
signalements n'hésitez pas à nous les
faire remonter je travaille beaucoup
avec vous et avec aussi les députés sur
certains signalements où nous avons en
lien direct et nous prenons des mesures
très fortes sur ces points et nous ne
flébirons pas parce que c'est trop grave
et nous ne devons pas laisser aller
voilà et je vous remercie pour cette
question il y av juste une dernière
question sur les les masters le bilan
oui pardon alors je l'ai donc alors je
n'ai pas le le bilan pardon excusez
final sur mon Master euh mais sur un
premier bilan et je pourrais vous donner
le bilan final car nous allons faire une
réunion de retour d'expérience euh
peut-être dire que euh nous avons une
augmentation d'à peu près sur la l'arrêt
de la plateforme donc avant le le le
recours au rectorat et au Commission d'
rectorat euh fin je dirais au au moment
de l'été nous avons eu plus de 10000
candidatures avec des propositions que
l'année dernière à même date donc cette
plateforme a permis de à 156000
candidats de recevoir une proposition
d'admission ça a représenté au mois
d'août 10000 candidats de plus à date
équivalent de l'année dernière donc nous
en avions eu 146000 l'année dernière fin
août à peu près donc je pense que il y a
des améliorations à faire sur la
plateforme nous l'avons vu nous allons
le faire c'est ce bilan que je pourrais
vous présenter dans chaque académie il
faut savoir que le nombre de de plac les
185000 places qui ont été ouvertes en
première année de de Master national se
supérieur au nombre d'étudiants qui ont
des licences donc au niveau des places
nous avons plus de places que
d'étudiants candidats ou que d'étudiants
qui ont des licences même avec les
candidats extérieurs et ce que va nous
permettre d'avoir cette plateform for
c'est la cartographie vous le disiez par
exemple sur le droit de là où par
rapport au type de formation ou aussi
géographiquement nous avons plus de
demandes ou plus et c'est cette
cartographie et ce bilan que nous
n'avons pas
encore